so Dave Chappelle
hosted Saturday Night Live and it was
one heck of a monologue
aside from the Kanye West commentary
about Jewish people in Hollywood which
is being slammed I guess by as
anti-semitic whatever Dave Chappelle I I
couldn't believe it he explained why
people liked Donald Trump and why they
still do and it was such a good point
that I think he may have just helped
Donald Trump right before we we hear he
may be announcing his presidential run
it was incredible Chappelle was like
here's a guy who comes out and says all
those things you think they're doing we
are doing it and they won't change it
it's there's more than that we'll pull
this up but I just I heard what Dave
Chappelle said and I was like I kind of
want to vote for Trump now wow I can't
believe he said something like that but
of course the media is pushing DeSantis
versus Trump which is probably way
overblown and then you've got the
mail-in voting problem so we'll take a
look at what's going on maybe you
noticed there's a story from Newsweek
where they said they're going to quote
unquote fix ballots in Colorado and then
Lauren bobert will likely lose
because many ballots were rejected so
once they cure those ballots well then
the Democrat will take over so we'll
talk about that plus a bunch of other
stuff Carrie lake is being advised so we
here I don't trust the media that she's
not going to win this because the votes
closing and her lead is still uh fairly
decent but we will see the battle is not
over until everyone gives up and I doubt
Kerry Lake will give up but we're
getting all that stuff before we do my
friends head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com to get virtual
Shield a virtual private network service
a VPN helps keep you safe as you browse
the web it's a basic layer of security
to stop creepy weirdos government
hackers or just regular old hackers from
stealing your stuff if you go to
surfinginternetsafe.com they've got a
special deal 8.33 cents per month that
is 72 percent off really really cool
stuff
you get the full identity protection and
VPN plus included social security
protection and real-time 24 7 alerts add
and malware blocking that runs
continuously dark web scanning behind
the scenes stream your favorite TV shows
and movies with premium streaming
priority custom support customer support
hide your IP address from anyone anytime
fight censorship from your own home this
is interesting because if there's some
kind of weird block that should not be
there the VPN can help bypass that stuff
it's a Global Network with
military-grade encryption and you get
access to unlimited devices with I
believe that's with a VPN plus so again
go to surfinginternetsafe.com and as
always virtual Shield the first sponsor
I've ever had back when I was getting
like 10 000 views on YouTube and they've
stuck with us the whole time so don't
give your money to people who hate you
support companies that have been with us
that's surfing internetsafe.com and of
course don't forget head over to
timcast.com become a member to support
our work directly click that join us
button sign up and you'll get access to
our on censored members only shows we
put those up Monday through Thursday at
11 PM we're gonna have one up for you
tonight which is going to be a whole lot
of fun so don't forget to also smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
take that URL post it paste it
everywhere top get the word out Word of
Mouth helps defeat censorship as well
the reason I say our uncensored show is
going to be extra fun is because joining
us tonight is Mr Dave Rubin Tim I gotta
tell you man you've become a
broadcasting professional when I met you
the first time you were a little
journalist you were a guy with a camera
and you had a little attachment on your
phone to make it prop up and I had never
seen that before and you had a beanie I
was like what's this guy doing what's
this guy doing and now you're running
like the biggest media Empire this side
of West Virginia a fraction of the size
of the daily wire but you know this side
of West Virginia doing all right man by
the way thank you I didn't know what we
were doing today but thank you for
leaving this gender queer book in front
of my uh microphone this is extremely
disturbing stuff I had to make sure it
before we got started
from YouTube If I read any of that yeah
man I think the the last we talked about
this last time I saw you was at your
comedy show in La I think it was yeah
that's three years ago we think that's
crazy three so we haven't seen each
other for three freaking years that's
how bizarre the world has been before
that I went on your show yeah and then
afterwards pulled out a GoPro and filmed
you and did a little interview with you
yeah and now uh and you know that was
back when I was traveling around and
doing more field work and now we're
totally off that basically and it's just
commentary and this sit-down topical
news show
as it goes just talking [ __ ] about
people yeah that's right seeing what
happens yep yep so I think most people
know who you are you host the Reuben
report
I guess I was early in on all this
internet craziness talking about stuff
normally I tell people to explain who
they are but I think I think most of the
people watching this probably know me I
would assume they all like me I've been
told there's a few people online that
don't like me but you know everybody has
their Their audience everyone's got
haters yeah yeah but you know I think
the the the side that we occupy is very
broad yeah and even your haters watch
whereas with the left that you know they
won't they won't even bother to listen
to the contacts or try and get the
information I've come to my haters
actually because they drive a lot of
clicks at the end of the day you know
and I always think it's funny that
there's a certain set of people that are
so obsessed with everything that I say
or any pause that I make or if I
slightly stammer over a word or a spot
any or they'll edit things to say you
know to take the word not out or
something like that and I'm like this is
what you guys are doing all day for me
like for me like it's good you know it's
it's hilarious in a way I don't do any
of that stuff I don't think you really
do any of that too right now like
there's a devoted group of people that
hate me and you because we're thought of
as sort of like f x lefties that are red
pilled something like that but do you do
videos like that like about whatever our
the version of us on the other side is
like I don't even really know who they
are exactly but they're not a waste of
time there there are there are prominent
speakers who make videos about both of
us non-stop all day there's like 50 of
them and I never talk about them yeah no
never because people I was like if we
did a show about
commenters commentators how is that
relevant to the average American how is
it to the average person who's trying to
so dribble you know it's funny so I I
don't even talk about The Young Turks
which people always used to ask me about
The Young Turks because obviously that's
where that's where I started at the
political level in LA or whatever and uh
I never comment about them but they do
all these videos about me all day long
okay fine but then finally on Election
night did you see that Jank tweeted out
that he that the power had gone out in
their Studio yeah and I just I
screenshot it I didn't even retweet them
because I was like I didn't want to tag
him and create like a fight but I just
screenshot it and I just wrote LOL from
Florida yeah and I was like that's good
enough like you vote in these morons and
now you can't get power at your studio
it's funny they you you sort of I don't
want to waste time with you know getting
too much into the intros but one last
point is you clearly realized something
was going on yeah your political views
start changing you say I'm getting out
and now you look at the people who
mocked you for it their power shutting
off in their studio and you're there
where it's free and it's awesome but
that but that is part of the adventure
it's like you know I realized something
early on because I was so in it right I
was in it with like the YouTube thing
and The Young Turks and these lefties
and I saw all the weirdness around
YouTube and all that [ __ ] and let's
let's let's save it because we have a
lot to save that yeah yeah so of course
back to genderqueer that's right of
course Lucas here as well yeah I don't
know about you guys but everyone loves
me
oh yeah especially in the comment
section I'm there with you guys and
today I'm wearing a shirt that says
y'all went from sheep to Lab Rats which
makes for a perfect conversation for
Thanksgiving family gatherings you could
say a lot without really speaking and
from the testimony from the European
Parliament from the news report by NBC
news from everything that we saw in the
last two years it's absolutely true if
you agree get the shirt on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com because you
do that's why I'm here thanks for having
me they say that like uh Gossip is one
of the weakest forms of communication
you know great minds talk about idea is
mediocre Minds talk about things weak
Minds talk about people so I'm kind of
with you guys on the whole don't slander
and slap off about other people but Dave
you you created locals and then sold it
to rumble and I made a comment there all
right so let's do it so I was talking
about you no no no we got to walk it
into it we'll save it oh okay so that
was me gossiping I think there is a
value to do it a little bit you know as
humans we're Community creatures and we
kind of live in a global community so I
tried the whole don't ever talk about
anyone thing and it's very isolating and
psychotic at some point I think it's
worth it well you can't do what we do
and never talk about people like you
can't you know what I mean you gotta you
can talk about ideas to the best of your
ability and you can talk about what's
going on in current events and then
every now and again it's going to slip
into something about people sometimes
who you don't know or haven't met or
just need more context for or whatever
but just real quick on the vaccine thing
because I can see you're freaking out
over there I am not vaxxed and I hope
that's okay with you guys I'm oh yeah
original pure blood uh did not get the
shot and I don't like people who did get
the [ __ ] did you get covered I did get
covered my legs hurt for a couple days
and that was it yeah you felt on your
legs we're not freaking out we're with
you I want to introduce
we got a story in that too but uh we got
Kellen here Serge is uh out for the
night yeah Serge is out I'm Kellen
what's up I'm ready to go all right well
let's let's get into the first story and
talk politics we got this from CNN
opinion Trump is adored by his followers
Dave Chappelle explained why this is
from uh Dean obadala I think you
mentioned you knew him Dave I used to do
you stand up with him let's just leave
it at that ah okay well I'll I'll put it
simply like you have the story here and
uh it's amazing let me read a little bit
they say Chappelle pivoted about halfway
through his monologue the topic of trump
remarking that quote I'm watching the
news now and they're declaring the end
of the Trump era he then melded his
acerbek comedy with a simple truth that
everyone wishing Trump would disappear
from at the from the political landscape
needs to hear Trump's base hasn't come
close to abandoning him I'm just being
honest with you I live in Ohio amongst
the poor whites a lot of you don't
understand why Trump was so popular and
very loved
he goes on a mansion Trump says I know
the system is rigged because I use it
the comedian then joked about how Trump
accused during the debate with Hillary
Clinton of not paying taxes and shot
back that makes me smart
Chappelle shared that for many
working-class Americans struggling to
make ends meet Trump's honesty in
revealing the rich and Powerful have
been taking full advantage of a system
designed for their benefit only enhanced
his stature
it's amazing and then he said Chappelle
pointed out that Trump looked at her and
said and you won't change the laws
because the peop because your friends
benefit from it too and when I heard
Dave Chappelle say that I'm like that
wasn't a joke that wasn't anything other
than powerful insight and a sales pitch
when I heard him say that it reminded me
of of the 2016 uh election what Trump
was on about and then I was just like
yeah I kind of like that he really made
me he really created a positive image of
trump they say Trump's going to announce
his running tomorrow and the weekend
before Chappelle comes out and says this
thing Trump did which is really sad
which is really really good people
respect I'm like
Wow's comments were very close to what
Michael Moore said in 2016 specifically
when it came to Middle Americans and
blue collar workers going for Donald
Trump because he represented the larger
ideas of the American working class
which he was representatively standing
up for but that then Dave Chappelle also
made a joke about Donald Trump taking
out his Illuminati card sniffing some
cocaine and then telling everyone how
they're playing the game and then went
inside to the White House and then
started playing the game which I thought
was also another important point there
but this could be one reason why he's
being criticized as quote anti-semitic
and and promoting uh anti-Semitism right
now by the ADL which I think is
absolutely ridiculous what he mentioned
in his comedy skit I think was perfectly
navigating a very sensitive topic he hit
everyone he made everyone laugh about a
very tough issue and I think his
representation of what happened to Kyrie
Irving and Kanye West was also something
important a couple days ago on my
members area I was talking about how
Dave Chappelle was on Oprah talking
about how people were trying to drug him
so he had to escape the huge contract
that he was under and literally went to
Africa this is also something very
similar that happened to Kanye West so
there's something to really think about
here when it comes to people who are
anti-establishment people who are
breaking from The Matrix people who are
coloring outside of the box I don't know
being heavily criticized and attacked
well look you color outside the box on
anything and they're going to come for
you remember when Rogan had Dr Malone on
what happened the week after the entire
mainstream media is saying Rogan is a
racist and they're releasing all these
videos him saying the n-word not because
he was actually racist but because he
was making fun of the user of the people
that use the n-word but that's what the
system does but I think actually what
you said about the timing is most
interesting because it's like wait a
minute we all saw that in 2016 I didn't
support Trump in 2016. I did vote for
him in 2020 and there's certainly a
chance I'll vote for him again next time
if that's where we're at but it's
interesting because Chappelle he must
have known that then and yet in the same
monologue Chappelle says I think he said
twice I'm a Democrat yep so it's like
well hey what still makes you a Democrat
I don't I don't really get that or maybe
that's his way of just throwing a little
something so that he's not
ousted immediately from the power
structure or something like that but
also it's like where were you for these
last six years when Trump was doing all
of those things that you're crediting
him for like that was day one stuff
right so it's one of those things where
it's like all right you got to the party
so there's the the IQ well there's the
IQ bell curve thing of trump I think
where actually that's probably a bad way
to put it but when you start to really
dig in dig in deep into Trump's
Administration you get a little soured
by it like John Bolton and um and and I
think Bolton was because of Sheldon
Adelson he was getting money from when
you when you actually look at the dark
nitty-gritty you're like my view of it
is the Trump Administration uh I said
this before Trump was the best president
of our lives that doesn't mean he was a
good president you know whether you
think he is or not is entitled to you my
point was that name another president in
my lifetime in our lifetimes who did a
better job the economy was great he was
getting our troops out of the Middle
East the foreign policy was was
generally improving Abraham Accords
peace with North Korea and I'm like that
was all good enough for me in 2020 to
say I will vote for him because I don't
like voting against people look we had
all-time lowest black unemployed women
all-time lowest Latino unemployment the
moment for me that like really kind of
started the shift because it took a
while because everybody kind of has
their own little journey to to get there
for me was that that uh State of the
Union Address when he's talking about
Lois all-time black and Latino
unemployment and then they flash to the
Congressional Black Caucus and they're
sitting there with scowls on their faces
and it's like wait a minute I thought if
you guys want one thing it might be for
black people to have jobs but they hated
Trump more than that they hated him more
than that they they hate you so much
they will vote for John fetterman
that's but that's that people walked
into I'd say they walked into a booth I
guess nobody walks into a booth anymore
people go to the Dropbox or whatever
they do they mail in their 18 ballots to
vote for fetterman how profoundly insane
is that it's this simple Dr uh this poor
guy he had it all think about Nancy
Pelosi and I know everybody watching
this save for a small minority who for
some reason are watching do not like
this woman despise this woman imagine
who you would be willing to support to
get rid of her
some bad people right but you know she's
worse right
you look at fetterman and they weren't
looking at Dr Oz like it was Dr Oz and
that's probably why Trump thought Oz
could win they looked at Oz and they saw
Trump and so they just said magabad
Republican bad if Trump's behind it we
vote for the other guy no matter what so
despite the fact that fetterman
he's got severe serious brain damage
yeah they wanted it but I will I will
also stress too
um because I pointed this out and I I
think you probably agree Republicans are
never going to win again so long as
universal mail-in voting is is the rule
of the land because people who are
disinterested from voting who normally
don't care are having ballot Harvesters
knock on their door and say did you fill
that out come on just fill it out yep
then they do
then they put in the mailbox or the
ballot Harvester collects it and a
person who normally wouldn't vote and
has no interest in voting is now voting
and it's creating this ignorant voter
base that votes just by by letter well
let's say most likely everyone watching
this can agree that to some extent
there's something Shady going on there
so let's hit it from the other angle the
other angle would be well what's going
on in Florida the great free state where
I live in Florida they cleaned it all up
and you gotta show an ID it was such a
freaking pleasure to vote in Florida to
go the after I've lived in L.A for a
long time no there were long lines
actually it was pretty functional went
right in school a smiley person standing
outside to walk right this way used an
actual pen paper actually put it in a in
a little folding envelope and walked it
over dropped it in the booth myself
somebody else said Thank you checked an
ID it was like Wow democracy actually
can work some of this can have some
value as opposed to La where you just
drive down Ventura Boulevard you just
yell out who your name you know yell it
out to the crack dealer and then they
whisper it and they vote Newsom long
lines Arizona machines not working
that's insane they still haven't figured
out who won
absolutely crazy did they fail math
Banana Republic [ __ ] when when literally
five days later or whatever no five days
what am I saying it's now we're seven
days out basically well again one of the
reasons why Florida got it right is
because back in 2000 when the election
wasn't counted on Election night people
lost their ish people were freaking out
now it's slowly being normalized which
is absolutely crazy but after that Gore
Bush debacle in Florida the state of
Florida invested a lot of money into
voting uh Ron DeSantis also specifically
passed the law Banning Zucker bucks is
what he called specifically money from
Facebook uh into Florida and I think
that also made a very big impact on the
state because Mark Zuckerberg spent
hundreds of millions of dollars making
sure that there was mail-in ballots
ballot harvesting and all that money all
that financing wasn't available in
Florida because Ron DeSantis stopped it
and I think that is what helped him win
here when almost everyone else lost Tim
do you think that part of it is also
that they want people to not have faith
in the system so they love all of this
not just because they're doing it better
than Republicans but it's also to break
the average person to just be like none
of it works I don't care just give me
some stuff and I'll stay home and
that'll be that like yeah no one ever
said it was going to be easy and I had
someone Super Chat they were like Tim
you told me to get all my friends and go
vote and I did and look what we got and
I'm like you won the projection right
now like the heart protection is 219 in
the house I mean hey maybe in a week the
mail-in vows will come and the
Republicans will not have one but uh
fortify they got fortified but but if
you didn't go tell your friends to vote
you'd be doing way way worse it is
difficult and here's what the Democrats
would love and the the Neo The neocon
Establishment Republicans as well they
would love it if everyone listening just
said I give up yeah because then
they don't got to worry anymore they say
great you've given up and now we own it
and we'll own you forever well it's the
ultimate black pill it's why I try to do
my show at the end I always try to give
some kind of positive thing at the end
because otherwise otherwise what are we
all doing right we're all talking about
these issues we're trying to I mean
you're a great example of it because you
moved a couple times to places to do the
work that you wanted to do because right
you could you didn't want to do it in
Jersey you didn't feel safe there
anymore
New York right yeah they murdered those
two cops in front of my house
so you you did it you took your foot
vote you took all the value that now you
create here and it's like people need to
know that there is a a place that they
can go to that is still functional
Florida is that as DeSantis called it on
Election night that is the Citadel right
now Texas has obviously a version of it
and Tennessee does and a couple other
places but Florida is the home of the
free but let me show you this tweet
right here we have this uh tweet from
Andrew Kaczynski you know me I love him
he says every single County moved
further right in New York this year if
it comes down to just a few seats New
York Democrats and backlash to
democratic policies rule in New York
will have cost them the house
so hokel wins zeldin loses but what how
many votes did he lose by so he lost by
about 350 and I told you right before we
started that over the last I think it's
three years in New York they've lost
over 550 000 people so if you just look
at that math alone zeldin had people not
moved but you know you have to put in a
zillion factors because Kobe made
everybody crazy and everything else but
it's like zeldin could have won the fact
that he even got up this close and they
flipped some of these seats is
incredible like that guy is the All-Star
DeSantis obviously is the the starter
All-Star from this thing but but zeldin
is is a close second every single
District in New York shifted left I mean
just one more time every single County
look at that shifted right sorry sorry
sorry shifted right shifted to from the
left to the right it's all one thing
when you look at it from space man the
far enough left and you end up on the
right but you but you mentioned 550 000
people I remember covering that story uh
hundreds of thousands from Manhattan
from Manhattan left and who would be
more likely to leave people who want
freedom where did they go across the
United States they went to Florida First
Texas second and what do we see both of
them became more red they they and
Georgia as well I don't know about
Georgia people moved there but you know
Kemp defeated Abrams handily DeSantis
gets this double-digit win and everyone
says things like he's a good leader he
had good messaging he cleaned up the
voting of the voting laws and and rules
all true but also consider all the
political refugees who went there and
wanted to vote for him they moved there
for him he attracted these people so
there's there's some good and there's
some bad and the bad is I was worried
about this that if people were going to
be fleeing yeah it would make red areas
redder and then you leave New York it
becomes Bluer in some respects though
that's how this whole thing was set up
to be right I mean the idea of
federalism that the states will be
extremely different experiments of
democracy and you will go somewhere that
is in line with your values that's
really how it was supposed to be you
know if New York
putting even New York aside because they
tried at least Cali just it's just never
coming back but if that's what they want
you know I still have some friends that
live there but it's like if that's what
you want I don't know what makes us
United anymore and unfortunately the
blue States will always encroach on the
red States Florida doesn't want anything
from a blue state right the blue States
will want the tax money and all the
resources of the functional red States
that's what that's what I think the next
Frontier but on the other hand we have
to understand Florida was a was a purple
is what I think was a purpose
barely won his first time around 30 000
votes so it was it was extremely close
and now this larger transition from New
Yorkers to Florida I think has
solidified Florida as a red State I
think there's like a but it's not what
they want sorry you said you said if
that's what they want in California but
it's not what's happening is
with with the the way their election
system works the more they weaken it now
they want to allow non-citizens to vote
yeah
a weekend election system means that for
all of The Selfish disinterested uh
voters they negate the Patriotic
hard-working American vote so for every
one of you out there who knows what's
going on wants energy policy fixed wants
Economic Policy fixed doesn't want our
borders open your vote is negated by
some guy who's playing Grand Theft
Auto's house when he has a knock on the
door and someone walks up and says
couldn't help but notice that you got
your mail today see that that's a ballot
did you fill it out and the guy says I
don't know man I don't care look just
fill it out it'll take 10 seconds and
then I'll leave and the guy goes okay
sure what am I doing Democrat okay here
you go man that one person who didn't
care canceled your vote even kind of but
what's happening is they're voting for
people to go do what you think they're
going to do and then they end up not
doing it because they get bribed like
this idea that we're in the best system
and this is the way it's supposed to be
I think is really messing with people
people think that they're in the this is
it we got there I don't think we need
like we only Built a republican like
representative house because we needed
to because people couldn't represent
themselves they didn't have telephones
now we could 700 000 people could vote
yay or nay on a vote but we've talked
about this direct democracy it doesn't
work direct republicanism we need a
republic that's direct to the people so
that we don't have these middle men that
are getting bought out by corporations
you want localism and you want
federalism so I I agree with you
actually that it's not that look first
off California has this basically the
most Republicans in the entire country
just because of the size of the state so
it's not that all of these people want
what they're getting there I would I'll
word it a little bit differently I would
say at some point you've got to just see
what day it is what time it is and you
got to get going and to me if you are a
freedom-loving person who wants to own a
business and feel safe and not have
genderqueer Jam down your kid's throat
and everything else get the hell out of
Cali it's as simple as that it really is
to address what Ian was saying I think
you make an interesting point though so
let's look at this map right here of New
York right these counties they all
shifted towards the Republican Party
if you didn't need to send your votes
from say Utica
to the the Secretary of State or
whatever determine which individual
would run the state but instead you in
Utica voted for what you wanted then uh
I guess the idea you're saying is that
you're you're more likely to have your
voice heard as an individual every time
it would be heard but it's not it's not
direct democracy it's the district gets
a vote basic basically so if there's a
member of Congress representing a
district instead the district does a
vote per issue or something like that
yeah so everyone in the district will
vote Yes or No and then the district
would be decided by that vote that would
go into the Senate so Congress would be
passing a bill and then the vote would
go out to uh everyone to see online and
then you'd vote in your district and
your District would get a vote based on
region but here's here's the point yeah
there's another there's some pros and
there's cons in this concept I mean for
one it still ultimately comes down to
ignorant people who don't care we'll end
up voting okay but Counterpoint it would
require the ballot Harvesters to go out
seven times a week to try and win these
votes and they wouldn't be able to do
that well that's one of the reasons that
the ballot harvesting works because
they're going to Blue cities blue cities
these are Democrats who want more
control they want more government in
their lives it's a lot harder to do it
you're going to go out to Utica and
you're going to go to Cornell and wander
around in the freezing cold and try to
get all these people people just aren't
going to do it that's that's the
Republican disadvantage but really think
about that we're staring at a freaking
completely red map with one one little
tiny dot of blue that people probably
can't even see if they're on their phone
and that is now governed by a Democrat
does that really make sense yeah
a Democrat who was one of the where I
would say the worst three heard Newsome
and and Whitmer one of the worst three
when it came to lockdowns and everything
else and the week before in the debate
she freaking said she would do it all
again and these people voted for her so
at some point if you're a sane person
there you gotta go all right maybe we
got a wrap up shop so here's the
challenge you leave New York and I've
said get out of the Cities go to the
middle of nowhere get some chickens
right you leave New York which makes it
you're basically clearing all obstacles
for for for these people to solidify
these rules and make them crazier and
worse you leave they will never lose
again you go to Florida you protect
Florida Florida and Texas seem to be
doing okay but all the other states are
now suffering and moving further and
further towards no you might have to
seed some ground I think we might be at
that place that all right here's what we
do
everyone in Florida have a bunch of kids
just start cranking them out 10 babies
per family then 18 years we send those
kids out all across the country start
colonizing blue cities listen I just had
two kids uh they're never they're never
leaving Florida these kids are gonna and
I'm being buried in Florida oh they're
going to be home schooled or we'll
figure out some pod thing although that
being said Florida actually has pretty
damn good schools because of Mr DeSantis
and his don't say gay and they booted
all that stuff out of the schools so
there actually are pretty good public
schools in in Florida I don't know what
we'll do exactly but I would be less
concerned about that in Florida which
was the joke because Florida has no no
state income yeah no there's no they'll
do that too
DeSantis also got involved in Local
School Board elections yeah and actually
gave out recommendations for candidates
that he wanted to win which made a big
impact which is affecting the schools
down there and nobody's gonna leave
Hannah Navarro from The View she's still
she lives in Miami she complains every
day and she's not gonna get it oh you
heard what she said about yeah about to
send us right that he gained the system
game the system by arresting people
committing fraud yeah
she seems to think that black people
can't get IDs a lot of black people
every single one of them but when she
was like he gamed the system he arrested
people who committed fraud and then
credit police it's like what do you
think you're saying to people right now
yeah I really want to bump into her at a
restaurant one day she's on my short
list of people that I would say
something really you might in Florida
although all the politicians this in
Florida go to Florida AOC loves Florida
she vacations down in Miami all the time
she had she had her own people masked up
in New York and she went to that
freaking drag bar in Miami Beach and
then they paraded her around like she
was a queen like how vile oh man another
example I want to get rid of the House
of Representatives I can't stand these
these faux celebrities getting
popularity contested into a bribery
state so annoying you know I don't I
don't I don't understand I don't know if
I agree with the get rid of the House of
reps but I do agree that um just because
we created this system which has been
one of the best so far or if not the
best
it doesn't mean we stop here you know
what I mean like there's there's always
got to be a way to do things better to
improve things you're right and I
shouldn't say get rid of the house I
don't that's not my intention is to
transition to a better form of
representation personal representation
well what if you just completely
handicap the federal government would
that basically do it for you short of
California because you're happy right
like that's what that's where we should
all be going for that way as you said
you moved to Florida you moved down here
I moved to Florida we're all making our
choices and then the only issue then if
the federal government is not that
powerful is that the blue states don't
somehow encroach on the red States it
will not go the other way so that's the
one thing we have to watch
foreign governments the feds kind of
protect the states from foreign
government interference they're supposed
to I want to show you guys this map real
quick this is the total vote count
I don't know if you guys knew this but
did you know that Republicans won the
popular vote
52.2 million to 47.2 million yet somehow
the Democrats and uh uh staving off this
red wave of the total votes there was
101 million so certainly not as much as
2020
um or even as much as 2016 it's a
midterm so I'm not surprised but uh
Republicans won the popular vote
well that's really incredible so when
they say that Trump is the problem that
Trump was dragging the Republicans down
it's absolutely not true they did better
than Democrats with all of the Maga
candidates and Trump support I think
it's a little bit hard to say because we
still don't it's hard to quantify the
amount of people that just hate him
religiously hate him as the ultimate
Evil and just will not vote for because
he's gotten involved so it's a little
hard to quantify that but the point is
either way Republicans did get more
votes and if again look at that that's
sort of like looking at the New York map
that thing's pretty freaking red and yet
we're pretty much controlled by
democrats I love this because what they
end up coming out and saying is it's
because land doesn't vote yeah
and I'm like okay let me explain food
let me it certainly does and there's two
things to point out first the
Republicans got more votes than you
Democrats that right there so when
you're like land it doesn't vote then
how do you justify losing the pot
popular vote this time and celebrating
your Victory hypocrisy no look I
recognize that the way the district
system is because it's not going to be
fixed for eight years when the new
census comes in because of all the
people who moved around and everything
like that there's a reason why this a
state is red or district is red it's
because Atlanta does grow food the
problem that I experienced when I went
to California is because they at a state
level they don't have a represent
representative system they have just you
vote yeah in to Larry County they ran
out of water
and the Farms the farmers were drilling
thousands of feet into the Earth for
groundwater the poor migrant workers
their homes ran dry their Wells stopped
working because the cities voted we get
the water
the surface water was given to the big
cities well because they needed more but
in reality what happens is if you have
one state and you say okay everybody
vote should we allow people to keep the
water that that's in their area or
should we allow uh should we have all
the water transferred to the cities okay
everybody now vote guess what two wolves
and a lamb deciding on what's for dinner
and the big city with its 13 million
people in LA county or whatever said we
vote to get your water they voted away
water from these other from these other
places that's why land has protections
because people live there and their
resources need to be protected based on
their interests yeah I mean you just
drive north from La go to a tribe from
New York to San Francisco and the amount
of signs you see on all of the Farmland
hey what are you guys doing to our water
basically it the proof's they're right
there San Francisco you said New York to
San Francisco L.A to San Francisco you
know what I'd love to see you know these
people don't understand what happens
when uh the Great Lakes get voted away
from the Great Lakes region there's a
lot of people who live up there there's
a lot more people who don't and a lot
more people on the west Coast who are
dealing with water crises and they want
that fresh water and they don't care how
they get it so let's put it up to a vote
Chicago Indiana Ohio Michigan and then
see how long the Great Lakes last when
Arizona says don't know much problem
don't care about your problem we thirsty
because there's already been issues
going back 10 20 years where Western
States who are in drought say they have
they have a right to the Great Lakes
which are an American Resource and one
of the only things that's stopping them
from actually getting it is Canada
Ontario which is part of the Great Lakes
Coalition this is why I'm like hey
there's a reason why Illinois has rights
over their resources and you can't vote
them away from them because it would
destroy it but if you don't live there
why would you care you know you want to
strip the resource for yourself it would
be it would be a disaster if we did
everything through direct democracy the
Democrats want it when you know when in
2020 when you know they are in 2016 or
in uh
when they have the popular vote but not
the presidential election but they don't
say anything about it now and the
Republicans have the pop have the
popular vote but not the majority well
the strong majority win it just seems
obvious to me we're just going to have
places that function in places that
don't and they're going to keep going
and the places and then they'll Purge
all their people as you're saying right
so the so think about how many it's not
just that 500 000 people left New York
it's the type of people that leave it's
people that have the resources to leave
that are like that are functioning that
are looking at the numbers and going boy
it just doesn't make sense here the fact
that I'm saving money by living in
Florida now is crazy to me I didn't move
because of taxes I was willing to pay it
you know La was nice I had a nice
operation there but the fact that now
I'm saving all this money too is crazy I
would have paid that money to get in and
now I'm going to push this ant is to go
Florida I wasn't willing to pay that
money especially in New York City yeah
paying city tax state tax federal tax
until you got out right I mean that's
the point yeah and now you go holy cow
I'm in Florida and it's better and I'm
saving the money too and how is it how
is it that Florida has roads isn't that
bizarre Florida has roads despite no
income tax Florida has better schools
property taxes no income tax no but the
property tax yes they do have high
property taxes but it's not it's
certainly not making up for what they're
losing in income tax at the end of the
year where they just take 10 of your
money or whatever it might be so Florida
declare independence and then uh I don't
want to the great Republic of Florida I
don't want to Jack anything today the
day before Trump announces I'm thinking
about like what do you do when there's
one big lake that a bunch of states are
pooling from like you want to vote
locally because no reason Nebraska
should be able to vote Away Great Lakes
water that makes no sense but at the
same time there's where you unification
of States there's no reason that
Nebraska should be not have access to
the state water so we're kind of in a I
mean the bigger problem actually is that
we're just we're in a massive culture
War as you guys know these people live
in another planet than us there are
people that want to be locked down there
are people who wanted to be injected and
force other people to be injected and at
the same time say my body my choice
they're we are living in completely
separate worlds and how you put those
people together mentally you know sort
of spiritually and mentally to live in a
country but then physically do it too it
may just be too big of a problem we
gotta mention uh The Young Turks
have you seen have you seen uh but this
this you know I don't comment on on The
Young Turks or other leftist common
commenters as any kind of drama or
anything like that I think there's a
really interesting political point to be
observed in gen yougger's tweets and uh
the production path he's taking you
notice that he interviewed Matt Gates
oh I know did it happen because didn't
the lights go out oh yeah well they got
him back up but at the very least he
announced he would be interviewing Matt
Gates and people I'm sure that went well
he came out against defund the police
which is a dip a stark contrast from his
initial position in 2020 supporting
defund the police who Jank yeah but
he'll take any position you know it's
like they'll eventually that's the point
look
he was he was going where the popular
context was right the popular position
in 2020 The Narrative was deep on the
police he was all on board I'm not going
to drag him for changing his opinion
I'll just say all right thank you Jank
for for adopting the appropriate
position again I think there's police
reforms we absolutely do need I'm not
the biggest fan of law enforcement but
that right just be I get rid of cops is
nuts now he's coming out with Anna and
they're saying things like we shouldn't
do this there are rumors about why that
is I guess wait shouldn't do what get
rid of the police oh so they're both
saying it now they're both saying it's a
crazy proposition you shouldn't do it
and that says something it says
something about the the shift in
politics that's occurring right now and
you know I'll put it this way when you
did that you know why I left the left
thing prageru was massive they started
coming after you saying oh he's faking
it he's a grifter and all that stuff and
then we mentioned this early on in the
show here you are in Florida in your
studio ever successful and The Young
Turks power went out and they had to
complain about how the mayor has failed
them and it's like it's amazing if they
saw what you saw or at the very least
they did but if they accepted that it
was true and were willing to say what is
true they would not be in a place where
their power is going out and now they're
changing their opinions though yeah so I
mean I have no need to really talk about
them but I would say that I swear to you
with every fiber of my being that all I
did was do what I thought the right
thing was along the way and then make
the choices according so I started
talking to people that were that were
different than me right like they every
day they'd be saying Ben Shapiro and
Larry Elder and Dennis Prager and Glenn
Beck they're racist and uh and it was
like all right well let me talk to these
guys and see what happens and then I
started talking to him and I go boy well
I guess I do disagree with them on some
stuff and I still have certain
absolutely you have disagreements with
them on a bunch of different things
things but they're nice they're generous
obscure they're kind they want to live
in a country with people that are
different than them and then I just kept
going down that road and then you and
then you know this too because you did
the same thing you go down that road
long enough and then you're like well
wait a minute now I want my life to fit
with that so I don't want to just have a
set of political ideas I want to live
those political ideas so for me that was
fighting as freaking hard as I could in
Cali for the recall recall was a
disaster I campaigned with Larry Elder
you know I got audited by the state
three days after the recall wow yeah so
this is what happens in Cali that's what
they do and that was the day I had
wanted to leave for about a year but I
was really trying you know the riots had
gone right by my house so I actually
moved because I was like if I move up
the hill maybe I'll be a little safer
but whatever I think and then I got the
hell out and now and now it's working
because I because I followed the true
path I really believe that I think uh
there's similarities and a bit of
differences between how we sort of
approached it for me I'd put it like I
grew up in Chicago and there's no
Republican party so the only thing you
know is Democrats and you hate them
as a young person growing up uh it was
an Arco Punk far left skateboarding
Etc and the Democrats were evil and we
didn't really know much about
Republicans my friends they there's
there's no there's no Republicans this
just doesn't happen and you got in the
suburbs and you're like there there was
no when I grew up I had no negative
thoughts about Republicans because they
were non-existent it did not impact for
the most part anything going on because
it's super majority Democrat across the
board so when I get older
I end up meeting a bunch of people on
the suburbs outside of the city who are
Republican and I have no ill will or ill
thoughts toward them because they did
not play a factor in in urban Chicago
living and then I started hearing their
opinions and and I'm like at this point
I'm eating chicken dinner with my
friends family who are conservative and
I don't know anything and I'm like oh
and so then I start shifting
from this young urban you know
skateboarding far Lefty activist into
more of like a moderate liberal position
where I'm like okay I totally understand
what these people are saying never
actually talk to him about it and then
as I get older what do you see you see
the media's lying they lie more they lie
more they lie more they lie more and
then what ends up happening is it's not
so much that people decide to become
conservative but that conservative
became a much bigger tent so I go to the
deplorable in 2017 and two people are
there they're like Tim we're big fans
and I was like really I was like I
didn't know I had a bunch of trump
supporting fans like no no we're
occupied we were big Bernie Bros but now
that it's Trump it's all the same thing
that red pill is a beautiful thing man
but it wasn't so much that these people
were uh I mean they were they were
liberal hippies yeah but Bernie Sanders
was their choice and with no Bernie it's
certainly not going to be Hillary
Clinton Trump was the other guy who was
talking about fixing our borders and
bringing jobs back and protecting unions
so he was the guy so people end up
voting for him not because they're far
right
but because he was closer to their
values as a populist and then of course
the weird insane cult left accuses
anybody who opposed them of being right
wing so now all of a sudden you and I
are conservative I guess I mean you may
have actually gotten more uh
conservative yeah well I well first off
I'm not by no stretch am I a traditional
conservative by the way anyone
understands the word conservative I mean
I wrote a book my first book was a
complete defense of Classical liberalism
and you know if you went through
everything in my book it's all the stuff
that Bill Maher would agree with I just
don't think he can stand on its own
anymore so I do think we do need a new
alliance and we're doing it right now of
sort of ex-libs and conservatives and
Libertarians and and caps and all of
these people uh it's basically we all
have to save the country and then we'll
deal with our problems after I think
that's basically where we're at you know
regarding As Trump the guy this is kind
of we talked about the beginning of the
segment well what happens is you know
when you try and start your car while
it's already going and it just like
Trump was the spot work trying to spark
the machine right now is not the move
let's let's talk about this thing I have
this tweet from interactive polls 2022.
this is interesting Iowa DeSantis up 11
Trump down 15. New Hampshire to Santa's
52 to Trump's 37 Florida descent is 56
to Trump's 30. Georgia DeSantis 55 to
Trump's 35. are they lying to once again
get rid of trump or is Ronda Santos the
new Star let's try it this way what
would you say the negatives on DeSantis
are because we can all do negatives on
Trump all day long and we can all do the
positives on DeSantis very easily right
it's pretty much everything but so what
would you say the negatives of DeSantis
are he passed anti-free speech
legislation the BDS Florida the BDS
stuff I think that's pretty important
okay what can you explain that
um I'm not that well read on it
specifically uh so I wouldn't want to
talk outside of my expertise to be
honest with you it was uh so boycott
divest sanction Israel yeah he came out
in favor of not allowing that I think it
had to do with universities but again
not allowing it as a state actor right
all right so it sounds like we don't
fully understand what it is but all
right let's and that's okay okay so but
I'm not I'm not even coming out uh as
that as a principle negative for
DeSantis mostly because it's not
something I know enough about to
criticize him on admittedly we
definitely want to make sure we check
into something like that because sure he
was infringing if he was infringing on
any free person's speech then I would
have problem with it but the government
is allowed to tell government employees
what they're allowed to do something
like that so I would need to know this
was based in University and school
specifically if a school would support
or allow someone to to criticize or
boycott Israel he would punish the
school and take away their funding but I
think it had to do with and Donald Trump
also had similar points of views and
viewpoints that he also supported as
well so it's it's it's it's a trump uh
DeSantis issue I'll put it this way I
think we are all too uh weekly versed on
the issue specifically but I do think
it's important let's say let's even say
it was a pretty bad thing so okay to
entertain the possibility that there are
things we don't like about them that
we're not well versed on I think is a
fair point however my view of DeSantis
is to be honest I can't think of a
negative however when you compare
DeSantis to Trump in in the event that
they go up against you know um when
they're on the stage Trump is an
imposing figure of grandeur who can uh
the way Milo put it is that when he gets
his mojo back he dominates the stage He
commands he pushes everyone out he shuts
him down now that is not a policy yes or
a practical Advantage it is a political
Advantage right so what's interesting
about that so I I actually agree with
you on that
um but he didn't really dominate Biden
in the debates and isn't that bizarre
now now knowing the degradation of Biden
and how bad he is and it was obvious he
was bad at the time but he didn't really
crush him in those debates so for some
reason Trump seems to be better when
there's multiple people on stage and
there's a Fray right and he can then
just sort of hit everybody but the
one-on-one thing was not his thing but
but also if at the end of the day the
the biggest weakness is that yes is
Trump more of uh I'm gonna get in the
ring with you and say all of the
horrible things and dig up all of the
evil [ __ ] and all of that to me I don't
know that most people see that as a
positive anymore I think people would
actually look at it and be like wait a
minute Trump what you're trying to do
here is take out the guy who has done
absolutely everything right using just
all of the worst tactics I just don't
know that that would fly anymore I like
what you said earlier when we were
downstairs in the Green Room you said uh
4D chess by mail it's the longest yeah
well that's everything with him is 4D
chess and it's like okay guys are we
gonna have her like does the game ever
end here I know a couple days ago I
tweeted oh no the 4D chess analogies are
back on online and I'm just like I I'm
so sick
Trump is so Advanced he surpassed M
Theory yeah one extra Dimension you
throw out a tweet every now and again
where I have to read it like six times
and then I'm like all right forget this
I don't know which way he's going on
this one that was one of them I was like
what is going on here is it 12d now like
where are we going but not also came out
a few days ago and says that he has dirt
on DeSantis that his wife doesn't even
know that he's going to be releasing to
the general public he said this on Fox
News even if it's true even if it's true
right whatever it is he cheated on his
wife and he did blow off a hooker's ass
and like whatever it is
political Behavior first off Trump's
done an awful a lot of bad stuff and I
just don't think if if you're willing to
do that now to the guy that's getting
everything done right it's like I just
don't think that's what Americans want
anymore I think there is a Long Leash on
our personal lives and that we've all
done stuff Trump proved it right Trump
proved you can sleep with hookers and
you can grab them by the [ __ ] and you
can do all that stuff and we'll still
vote for you so if his move is well
DeSantis has done kind of all the policy
right so I can't get him on that but I'm
gonna dig up something to derail him I
think it's going to have more blowback
than and it has and it has right now
especially with these numbers that that
Tim is showing but also I would question
the numbers because the numbers and the
polls have been wrong a lot but the
conversation in my opinion should be the
anti-establishment versus McCarthy
McConnell but it's not it's the
anti-establishment versus The
anti-establishment Wing of the party
kind of having a civil war within each
other destroying each other rather than
of course building and growing and of
course fighting the bigger fights out
there fighting themselves and
essentially eliminating and destroying
any potential of a populist surge that
that could be there well to that point I
mean we don't even know if census is
going to run I mean the guy loves
Florida like I honestly I know him
fairly well now and I've done a bunch of
things with him like the guy freaking
loves the State of Florida
he loves it look what he's done there
like maybe in part of his head he's like
hey I'm 44 years old I got this
beautiful young family like I'm riding
high right now maybe my life is to just
fortify the place that I love and do
great things they're like we don't know
what his plan is but when he was asked
directly he gave a perfect political
answer not answering the question
during the debate as Governor which made
it seem exactly like he's going to be
running like any politician so let me
give you some Insider context on that I
was actually at the debate and right
before the cameras started they
announced to the crowd that was in the
room they said the candidates have
agreed and signed a document saying that
they will not ask each other questions
so when DeSantis just stood there it was
because he was honoring what they signed
Charlie Christ has no morals and and or
anything else so Charlie Chris knew
exactly what he was doing that's not to
say DeSantis shouldn't have had a better
response he should have said no well he
should well or he could have said hey
Charlie we actually just signed
something that said we're not going to
do that do you have any do you have any
morals do you have any we we talked
about what happened we did the math on
it uh there's no upside to doing
anything other than saying no right if
if he said are you if he said are you
going to run for president or what he
said was are you gonna uh commit to
finishing out your term as Governor
because I just could have went yes I do
thanks Charlie have a nice day and just
end it yeah because if in the event in
the future things change he can say
something like I know I vowed to be here
for the State of Florida but I decided I
can be as the President of the United
States I can do more for Florida and for
the rest of this country and I will make
sure that Florida stays true you know
say with my heart I think that advice
probably would have been better than to
he sort of did just freeze in the moment
but he was trying to honor the agreement
that they had just signed and you know
that's the problem when you when you
play with one guy that has rules you
know what Trump would have done
well what would have done
if he was asked are you going to honor
your uh commitment to be Governor Trump
would have been like I thought we agreed
we weren't going to ask each other
questions when did you stop beating your
wife Charlie yeah exactly he would have
done something like that
that would have worked in the debate
context so your your point basically is
that even if DeSantis has everything
right and let's say let's just say
minimal uh downside it's like he might
get just crushed in the theater of the
thing that's that that is but it is
possible it is possible imagine it's
really crazy I was watching um you know
we're playing music videos downstairs in
the green room we have that voice
activated TV that that you didn't like
yeah what are you doing thank you thank
you Dave I've been screaming about this
I was like the CIA is listening every
single day
you Tim pool of all people you're
talking to your Google television it's
one TV in the whole house
that 20 of you were standing in coming
up with your plans to take
when we play the music videos these
these political ads would pop up where
they're just lying and it's the craziest
lies I've ever heard and I'm just
thinking to myself how do they get away
with saying things that are so look I
get it you can have your opinion in
politics and it's hard you know you've
got times to be Sullivan defamation
precedent stuff but when you come out
out Ryan be like my opponent said X and
he didn't it's just kind of a crazy
thought
I'm just like you know what I want to
see
just look Republicans if you're going to
win right now you can do two things you
can play the game of lies or you can
offer fifteen thousand dollars to
everybody who votes for you like Joe
Biden did basically but I'm imagining
you go up on stage and pull pull the
play the game are you gonna stay and
commit to being Governor when did you
stop beating your wife when did you stop
touching your children you want to play
games let's ask I I didn't say he did I
asked him when he stopped that's that's
that's that's the level of politics
right and people will immediately
believe it even though you didn't say he
did you can say when when did you stop
stealing from the local grocery store so
in a way you're making an argue you're
making an anti-trump argument I think
because your argument basically is he
could open maybe he sort of did this and
it needed to happen the person but he
might open up the gates of hell here
right like if if it gets to the two of
them and it's like DeSantis is winning
on policy and you know it he feels
fresher and it's right and there's a
track record but Trump is willing to do
the craziest [ __ ] known to man which I
think we would all agree he would do and
again I voted for the guy and I think
you right so that says some that says
something about Humanity I suppose it
does and it's something very dark
you know
Ben Shapiro he says facts don't care
about your feelings quite assuredly he
does and he gets a hundred plus thousand
retweets on Twitter he pins it and all
of the conservative smugly pet each
other on the back in their victory of
how smart they are in reality and but
they're not wrong they're not wrong but
but I say this rather aggressively
because
feelings don't care about your facts and
you can come out and say well if Joe
Biden were to shut down the Keystone
Pipeline it would cause speculative
Drive meaning the the investors and the
Traders are going to realize Supply
won't meet demand in the coming years
because the pipeline was shut down and
thus prices will increase so the invest
now causing an early price increase and
the average person goes huh and then Joe
Biden comes out and goes look at here
man I'm gonna give you ten thousand
dollars you know put in your body come
on man and they go well ten thousand
dollars sounds pretty good I'll vote for
him
keep it simple make it understandable
Donald Trump gets on a debate stage with
Ron DeSantis and Ron says in the great
state of Florida we kept our businesses
open we saw our economy improve
unemployment went down and Trump's going
to go well I think you're ugly and
everyone's gonna go whoa start clapping
and cheering I know and I'm I think
personally I'm just past that part and
that I mean that may be where we're at
like I think we need enough how about
something like this I think we just need
more adults in the room I think too many
of us have just let go of that uh part
of ourselves in a way did not want to
confront all of the scary mean things
out there and maybe we just need a
little more of Jordan Peterson like like
stand up straight with your shoulders
back and and just not be part of the
slow descent to hell I think that's true
I'm wondering if anyone could get into
the presidency and not get assassinated
acting like Kennedy be like the CIA I'm
uncovering at all they they know where
the guy lives like so is it more of a
local adulthood that you're trying to
create well I think DeSantis could like
you know I don't want any of these guys
to get assassinated even the ones I
don't like but you know I think that
there is room for a sane competent
person I think if we had a same
competent person as president and we do
not have a same competent person right
now and Joe Biden if we had someone who
people believed he believed what he was
saying and was roughly honest and things
kind of worked I think people would let
go of so much of the other [ __ ]
happening in society right now but right
now we know it's what you just said we
know everything is a lie everywhere
constantly everything that they say is
misinformation usually is truth all the
good guys are the bad guys the bad guys
the good guys so people are willing to
do anything in a situation like that and
I think that's what's so refreshing
about Florida it's like oh we got we got
breaking news Katie Hobbs has one
Arizona reports decision desk that they
have flipped the Republican state to
Democrat as of 8 50 p.m with 98
reporting Carrie Lake was still down and
unable to win there were not enough
remaining votes so uh they're calling it
what do you think Harry is going to do I
don't think she's going to take this
line down she better not uh I think
she's gonna file some lawsuits they they
absolutely should she has standing here
and she has to move very very quickly on
this one uh look if the people of
Arizona legally respectfully voted for
Katie Hobbs uh so be it so be it but in
today's day and age with the way this
country is going uh Carey Lake
absolutely should not and
in order to solve the problem of 2020
and now 2022 with ballot harvesting and
Universal mail-in voting the long lines
the adjudication the broken machines you
need standing and that standing just
happened right now Kerry Lake negatively
impacted by fire lawsuits now
and it's entirely possible the State of
Arizona is gonna have judges who just
say no thank you have a nice day as they
did in 2020 but this is the way the way
it works so now now Begins the legal
battle
which I think should happen and I think
there's one there's two things to say
about Arizona one universal mail and
voting as I've I've described Ad nauseam
mom says come on kids we're going out to
dinner her 18 19 year old kids will live
at home because the economy is in the
gutter and then she says before we got
to dinner fill out your ballots and
those kids go Mom I don't care about
this and just just fill it out and we'll
go to Olive Garden unlimited breadsticks
so they do that greatly helps Democrats
Republicans don't have that same ballot
harvesting game the bigger issue
with Democrats doing that and then
Republicans going in on Election Day and
this is partly Trump's fault the
machines were busted many of the
machines weren't working videos popping
up of them rejecting bouts bouts were
the the ink wasn't wasn't properly laid
so the machine was having trouble
scanning it then they had to put them in
and adjudicated some people were leaving
because the lines were too long
disenfranchising Republican voters and
probably I would argue enough that is a
problem that must be adjudicated it must
be solved in the courts uh otherwise
this problem will never be solved if
there's one thing Kerry Lake can do even
if she doesn't become governor she can
stop the broken process so the next time
around this doesn't happen I need to
confirm Katie Hobbs is in charge of the
election in Arizona yes and she did not
recuse herself obviously and neither did
Brian camp in 2018. yeah this is like
well a huge deal that someone is in
charge of an election they won and it
was in 2018 with Brian Kemp and he's the
Republican same thing he was the uh he
was in charge of the elections the
Democrats cried foul he ended up winning
and they claimed he disenfranchised
voters to win I'm sorry to cut you off
no no and Stacy Abrams then spent four
years screaming that she was basically
the governor what's also what's also
interesting about about Hobbes is that
Hobbes refused to debate Carrie like so
when you talk about how fetterman you
know had obviously has some level of
brain damage or whatever the stroke did
him on top of all the bad ideas and
everything else so Democrats can put up
candidates that barely can speak
fetterman and Biden and they can also
now put up candidates who literally will
not debate the other person this is a
huge problem it's it's a it's a function
problem but it's it's a problem it's
like
how you remember that but was it about a
month ago when she said uh well you know
we're busy with fundraisers so I don't
think I'm gonna have time for a debate
you know well then that seems
disqualifying I I I I think
you know I was talking about this the
day after the election I wake up and I
see all these Republicans like how could
this have happened is this Trump's fault
and you know uh just I'm like I don't
understand why is everybody so mad the
Republicans won like they they the
projections were 224 in the house now
it's 219. maybe in a week I'll be like
well I guess they didn't win because
more ballots came in and they cured them
or whatever I don't know yeah they're
saying Lauren Bowman might lose now but
um as long as the Republicans take the
house that's it they buy one vote they
change the speaker Pelosi's fired and
then they can start subpoenas and and
all that stuff and uh fingers crossed I
think they're projecting like 97 90
chance that's what's going to happen now
at this point and I'm like what more
could Republicans have wanted if he got
the Senate then you get Rand Paul on
that you don't have to send it yeah you
get Rand Paul on the on the health
committee you can ask about your
questions he's already done that so
they're not going to pass laws there's
no veto proof majority Biden wouldn't
allow it I think there's there's two uh
Silver Linings here with fetterman
winning you're not now going to have
endless memes about how insane the
Democrats are for electing this guy
they're going to try and keep him out of
the press
to a great degree yeah and also it uh
sort of absolves Republicans of any
responsibility for the downturn that
happens so as bad as it's been over the
past couple of years and it's not going
to improve already they're talking about
the economy is expected to get worse
there's going to be a major economic
crisis next year the Republicans can be
like hey y'all vote a Democrat we barely
got the majority by one by plus one
seats so you know don't look at us 2024
There's an opportunity if they fix the
universal mail right that's the thing
that's what I was gonna say it still
comes down to that because things are
pretty shitty now you know we're in a
recession although they don't call they
change the definition of recession so it
doesn't quite count the supply chain
stuff just try to order something from
Crate and Barrel see how long it takes
try to buy a window right like literally
anything
um so there are a million things on top
of the fact does anyone in this room not
think that Joe Biden is mentally
compromised or anyone watching this is
you know you said you didn't want to get
booted off YouTube tonight it'd be very
nice yeah compromise but the point is
you all know there's something wrong
with the president we all know that none
of this is working as I said that
there's just lies everywhere and we just
keep going with it well we don't well no
right the problem is the male info
machine or whatever so so when when did
you realize Joe Biden was not all with
it was it uh battery next now recent
Trinity pressure or was it um
the pronunciations are pretty solid on
those things because you know I work
easy words just you know intentionally
should have done a shop at a pressure I
sat and listened to that to try and
really get oh and now he's got relaland
yeah you saw that one right that was
just a couple days ago yeah rule of the
land he's trying to say perhaps I'm not
here to translate Biden true
International he's got two words America
is back like everything made in America
I got two words well that's what it was
made in America this matters you hear
them say that a lot and this matters but
yeah we what we just witnessed I I don't
see Republicans winning ever again I I
talked about this specifically in my
earlier video today now you could
criticize Donald Trump since his main
issue for this midterm was talking about
the 2020 election you could criticize
them from doing fundraisers for Masters
and and receiving 99 out of a hundred
dollars and giving only one dollar to
Masters that was uh uh you know that was
that was outpaid for by his opponent 80
million dollars to 12 million dollars
you could criticize them on that but
when you have the ballot harvesting when
you have the mail-in ballots
additionally when you have big Tech
censorship when you have yellow bellies
and neoconservatives in the Republican
party I don't see them winning ever
again in the near future what else could
help them win they have no institutional
power to change any of this they won't
change anything and even if they did I
wouldn't even have any uh you know
optimism that they would so I think
you're making my earlier argument which
is sort of you strengthen the red States
and you bring in all the good people
from the blue States
yeah you let the blue States crumble
under the weight of Their Own [ __ ]
and you strengthen you bring all of the
productive people you bring all of the
productive companies you hire based on
skilled instead of equity you do all of
it right and then you save certain
places and then
you just kind of go man it was beautiful
in the 80s and the 90s but we we
couldn't hold on to it that's a good
argument because even like 20 brilliant
people can completely transform a state
of course but you don't even need 20 of
them yeah look what's happening in Miami
right now they took all of the
worthwhile Talent from Silicon Valley
they didn't take all the social justice
Warriors they took the main people from
Silicon Valley they brought them into
Miami Suarez is doing an incredible job
he literally I mean it was the Tweet
right his tweet was how can I help and
he basically brought an entire industry
there and Miami is exploding as opposed
to imploding which is what's happening
well we chose we chose West Virginia
and we've actually uh we've moved
employees to come out to the area we're
expanding the operation we're starting a
couple new businesses and we're going to
continue to expand our West Virginia
operation the cities here are very small
but it's surrounded by uh it's it's it's
really interesting we're only a couple
we're three hours from Pittsburgh we're
three hours from Philadelphia we're an
hour from DC an hour from Baltimore
we're two and a half hours from Richmond
we have all these major Urban centers
all around us but we're in a red state
with a lot more freedom it's not perfect
West Virginia's got issues but we're
gonna fix them we're gonna fix them
there's a big opportunity here in the
land being cheap there's airports nearby
they have infrastructure Central West
Virginia is another story but I think we
can do a lot of good here and and um I
came down here because you know a friend
recommended coming out and coming down
here and now I see great opportunity and
uh I looked I've been looking at the
local uh representatives and the the
Congressional reps and they're based you
know they're like Ron Paul type
politicians and I'm like this is a good
opportunity
I look at Florida and it's incredible
but that weather man
you're talking about the weather is
freaking awesome I live in Miami I was
there all summer yes it's humid it is
and they have a statue to the guys
yes there's a thing called an air
conditioner and it conditions the air
there's bigger inside respect to that
guy no brilliant Adventure
being here right now it's like 20
degrees outside and you got AC going on
in here right now so yeah that was not
my fault so someone turned the AC on I
have no idea why it's 40 degrees Tim's
gonna go through a transformation where
he removes the beanie and goes to
Florida I lived in Miami oh wait a
minute were you wearing a bikini issue
with you that's what this is oh yeah I
lived in Miami yeah and the issue is
when there's two months out of the year
you can skate and it's January and
February I'm telling you I just was in
Florida this morning in Miami it was
about 72 abs absolutely beautiful the
iguanas okay November December January
this is a beanie issue with you it is
you don't want to be the guy in the
sweaty beanie oh there's the sweaty
beanie that's not true because I'm
always the sweaty beanie guy no but
you're obviously sweating a lot less
here you don't want to be August sweaty
beanie Tim and people have you
experienced Chicago summer my friend uh
Chicago in the summer it is absolutely
not the issue because I actually use the
beanies as sweat rags and I strain them
out as I'm skating and I'm not I'm not
exaggerating anybody who watches me
skate knows that it's it's black then
because it's you always wear black and
you feel like you'd be very out of place
there it's very hip yeah if you watch
the castle Vlog you'd see me wearing a
light blue helmet and a white shirt
while I'm skating oh so it is gonna
happen you're telling me because I'm no
no no no you've got a sweat rag on your
head you've got your neon colored
clothes it always looks slow when you're
already transformation up close getting
getting ready no uh Florida is expensive
that's that's the real issue it is
expensive they have to work on that we
looked at uh I I looked at Florida and
it's expensive and West Virginia was way
more land way cheaper way more freedom
we can shoot guns yeah Florida's
definitely got places you can do it you
could go down to Homestead that's where
that's where I lived yeah oh is that
right I mean there's land and there's
guns
awesome just north of uh Homestead and
um what was the street number I don't
know it's the Redlands yeah Redlands
yeah yeah I lived over there for a year
we had a five acre property we had
chickens and it was it was it's
beautiful during the thunderstorms man
it's really really amazing the
thunderstorms roll in five times a week
yeah and then we're just sitting
watching the trees so now you're telling
me how great the weather Temple we had
so many coconuts it was insane how many
coconuts we had we had too many coconuts
so you have coconuts you have the storms
that you're happy about you know I'll
tell you the weather is not really that
relevant compared to the good laws
especially you know I talked to
everybody here I said if if Rhonda
Santos really gets this law passed on
social media protections we relocate an
instant yeah
listen I I don't want to speak out of
turn here I just know they're working on
a million things they're working on ESG
stuff like they are doing everything
we're asking so for all of these people
out there as I tweeted this morning if
you think that Ron DeSantis is part of
the machine and he is just one of the
generic ones and he's just a Romney or
something like that it's like man he's
done everything you've asked he's
crushing in elections like there will
never be somebody good enough for you if
that's your take on it that's the crazy
thing you you tweeted something I
thought was really good you said Rhonda
Santos is doing everything we're asking
for and he's winning and people are
accusing him like this is yeah this
proves that he's bad right because you
because people have been so beaten into
submission that when the good thing
happens they think it must be transitory
something like that but it doesn't have
to be it doesn't have to be if we then
go and start building the proper
institutions which is exactly what he
did he cleaned up voting knowing that
he's not going to be around forever I'm
still skeptical of DeSantis especially
with him not being able to pass
constitutional carry in in Florida but
at the same time well they just got a
super majority now which if he does I
mean all out respects when he if he does
push this through uh but he does go
against the trans agenda he shipped
illegal migrants to to Martha's Vineyard
he's fighting fiercely against the ESG
social credit score and
how about how can you call him
establishment it's just crazy and then
and then Florida was one of the few
states that survived the whole weight of
all the lockdowns of all the
restrictions they were the number one
state that was attacked for allegedly
killing people by allowing them to be
free and they stood up against it and he
stood up against fauci more than
anything AOC went to vacation in Florida
with no mask you gotta change his
wardrobe it's the suit makes people
think he's establishment being in a hot
Florida sun in a suit do you think it's
maybe that a certain set of people just
use the phrase establishment to mean
just sort of anything that's like
somewhat normal you know he's got he's
got people like Ken Griffin yeah you
know who's come out supporting him and
Ken Griffin was the money guy Citadel
guy establishment funding but my
attitude is I mean who who did Trump
have him funding like exactly but my
answer is this look just because someone
when they went after I think it was
Rubio they said you're getting money
from the NRA they own you and he says
yeah he's like I don't get take get
money from them because I do things for
them I get money from them because I'm
doing things already and they want those
things to happen yeah that's the thing
DeSantis is winning I think these people
are like well it's Cults Communists
critical race Theory or DeSantis I'll
take DeSantis yeah look it's very
obvious that I was in I did a show with
DeSantis in Orlando it was the last show
on my book tour in Orlando so we went to
Disney country and everybody there
everybody there was psyched to see the
guy excited we had people in the meet
and greet coming up to me after that
were Disney employees that could
potentially lose their job if he cuts
you know if he gets rid of these tax
benefits and everything and they were
coming up to us telling how uh telling
him how appreciative they were so
everyone has moved on this stuff nobody
wants this everyone knows that this woke
nonsense in schools and talks second
grade teachers talking to kids about sex
or gender identity or call imagine you
had a kid and you found out that the
teacher the third grade teacher male
teacher was talking to your daughter
secretly about sex and calling her a
boys name or vice versa any which way
you want to play that like we all know
it's wrong but again we just need more
adults to be like hey we're here we
forgot yeah we were supposed to be with
a sick sexual fantasy for a teacher to
do that to a kid Twisted but with um
Twisted with universal mail-in voting
we're talking now
um you know let me see if I can pull up
a a tweet from myself to show you
identify exactly what the problem is
this image that will make all of you it
will it will make you per it will
perturb you if if nothing else let me
see if I can uh here we go
check out the sweet Western Maryland
literal Maga country with flags and
signs everywhere surrounded by
Republican districts to the west but
still broke for the Democrats after a
week of late counting elections today
are all about how the votes get cast and
not about how people actually feel take
a look at this beautiful little little
handlebar there in Maryland you see that
thing now look at this tiny little strip
you mean to tell me that this river
right here that cuts along here that as
soon as you cross that you immediately
go like I no longer like Donald Trump
now I'll vote Democrat I assure you
that's not the case you drive along this
and just like the districts of the North
End of the South it is Maga country with
Trump Flags Trump Signs Now how did this
District after redistricting which
became an R plus District go Democrat
it's the way the votes get cast mail-in
voting favoring ignorant people who
don't care they were projecting that
this would go Republican to Neil Parrott
and then at the last minute they started
counting new bouts new bouts new bouts
then slowly the Democrat flipped and as
soon as he did they called it
that's nothing is going to matter
moving forward because it's exemplified
right there so you know we can talk
about DeSantis doing everything right
but when it comes to the National level
if we have the Democrats in control of a
machine that it does it doesn't matter
if you know what's going on in vote
they're going to to find people who
don't know and don't care and they will
outnumber you again that's why I'm not
selling you on the federal government
here and I'm not selling you on the
grander project I'm saying certain
states can do it right and if you care
about any of these things then you have
to think about your life very seriously
and every time I tweet that out you know
you can move you know every well it's
not easy to move yeah it's not easy to
move whether you're single whether you
have a family your grandparents you got
kids whatever you have no money you're
rich everyone has their own
considerations but it is your life and
you have some capacity to do something
in your life and you got to decide what
you want to do because they set up State
elections uh so that you could vote
online and use like a blockchain to
confirm the votes could they do that
without the federal government saying no
you're not allowed I think that would be
worse could a state do it supposed the
state could do it I don't know
and you'd log into your account and it
would say thank you for voting and you
go I didn't vote though and they would
say it's on the blockchain you can't
change it but but I didn't vote I didn't
log in
yeah you should be able to confirm it
you got to be able to confirm your own
vote but I feel like voting on paper
giving it to Dominion or another
Corporation to tally the votes in secret
is like sticking your finger in a light
socket over and it's like oh I still
don't know if they cheated or they
didn't cheat paper ballot you need to
know you need to verify yeah even that
who's who's counting it like it's
unverifiable I want a verified election
what do you mean it's unverified someone
takes it says thank you we're going to
count this honestly they go to someone
else and they're like yeah we counted it
honestly that's right you get an
independent a Democrat or Republican and
whichever other parties like libertarian
and they all watch this I don't want
four people to decide to verify for me I
want to verify my own vote I don't need
other people they're doing it for me
well in Florida you could verify your
vote that you voted online you get a
receipt I did at least and it's like oh
here's where you voted here's who you
voted like the count should be happening
by a computer in public I think we
should follow what Florida did I think
Florida made a lot of mistakes
especially in 2000 but I think they they
shaped up they know they have 99 of the
vote counted by by midnight that that's
impressive that's something that we
should strive to of course to achieve as
well that's something that I think
should be universally put out I think it
was staliness that doesn't matter who
votes but it's who counts no that was
Biden oh Biden no no I think it was
Stalin first and then Biden said it no I
know yeah but Biden did say it so and I
fully agree with that if other people
are counting your vote for you then
that's a problem you should beat yours
should be you know here's here's the
answer uh you know shows like this are
fantastic uh shows like yours and Luke's
but um we're preaching to the choir I
think culture is is everything so almost
almost all this I think basically
everything we've invested in at timcast
from you know all of you becoming
members at timcast.com has been cultural
it doesn't mean we're gonna be Disney
but we're certainly going to try and
have cultural influence making music
we're working on a video game we're
working on a show we're working on now
movies because you need to instill your
values in cultural things there needs to
be an industry where artists can Thrive
there needs to be an opportunity for
that guy who works for Disney to say you
know what I'm not making this woke movie
I'll go work for someone else right now
there isn't every company is doing the
esgbs ever so these people are like if I
speak up I'll lose my job okay well we
need to build that out the daily wire's
got an apparatus for it we're we're
slowly expanding that you just need to
keep doing it and as Society will will
grow great when men plant trees whose
shade they know they will never sit
beneath so maybe in 50 years maybe in
100 years I'll long be dead and there
will be some weird Tim cast company
that's got libertarian Freedom love and
liberal values or whatever and it's
supplants or displaces the weird woke
ESG stuff we Inspire young people to
build it they will come yeah something
like that like you may as well try to do
something on your own to defeat this
thing rather than saying oh my God if I
only had that politician there are going
to be a couple transformational ones
obviously I feel that about DeSantis but
let's just make it let's let's uh hire a
bunch of young Tick Tock influencers to
just talk about how how uncool it is to
vote Democrat they won't vote Republican
they'll just say vote voting for
Democrats is so lame you're so lame I
can't believe you would do that did you
see the thing the other day where Biden
brought the tick-tockers into the Oval
Office and then they stage this idiotic
q a and one of the questions is should
Elon Musk be looked at by the federal
government and then he fumbled of course
through the answer but it's like yep
that's what I mean about everything's
fake it's all Bs we can see it we've
looked behind the curtain we've seen the
wizard we know he ain't the all-powerful
full eyes but what do we do about it
well one thing we can do is and and I
strongly encourage Rhonda Santos to
begin immediately is to start building a
dike system outside of Florida and then
draining the water to expand the
territory of Florida to accommodate more
and then you know I I've Breathing Room
breathing living in Miami I mean the
water is only three feet deep like 10
miles outside or like whatever it's I
think it's like 11 miles south of Miami
the water is like you could stand there
on the Rocks yeah that's crazy they have
stiltsville where they built those
buildings on stilts where it was like
international waters or whatever I've
been there it's crazy so you want to
literally like expand the land of
Florida yeah I don't think we need it
yet but we could start I think his next
thing like it is infrastructure projects
let's build more housing so that the the
competition that you were talking about
earlier about the house prices you know
here's here's a question if uh if Ron
DeSantis and this is totally
hypothetical If he if he brought in like
if he started actually bringing in Earth
ass yeah and dumping it alongside the
coast of Florida expanding would the
international waters go out with it or
how would that work that is a good
question I'm not a maritime lawyer yeah
um it's a very good question talk to my
Maritime lawyer he's an Entertainer yeah
it's like well you know the the water
extends to 11 miles to like
international waters but you know we
added a couple more miles of dirt well
most Florida's swamp anyway they have
pumps in Miami to get the water out so
and it gets flooded a lot so yeah I mean
it's but it's already gonna happen we
get flooded but you know hurricane Ian
hit basically a category five as he
described it a hundred year biblical
storm the I met a guy at the at the um
election night at the DeSantis event
election night it was a contractor in
South Florida and he was one of the guys
working on the the Sanibel Causeway and
he said that this thing would have taken
two years in any other state because of
all of the red tape
two weeks let's let's talk about
Solutions in in cultural in the culture
issues so before the show we mentioned
that Ian went on when a tirade screaming
and slamming the table about how Dave
Rubin was a sellout and if he ever got
the chance to see him in person he'd
tell Dave exactly what he's like razor
blades that's why I came here too um
well it's Segway is going to sit up well
so let me let me set this up it's um
we're dealing with censorship Elon Musk
buying Twitter and all of a sudden the
game has changed and a lot of this bodes
very very well for those who care about
freedom
we it seems like we're starting to make
tremendous gains in the culture wars but
with the daily wire success with Elon
Musk buying Twitter they can only they
can only hold on for so long with
universal mail-in voting with uh within
this there's Rumble which we use Rumble
infrastructure for timcast.com like the
whole website like literally the website
itself yeah the video player itself and
then we use parallel economy for our
memberships which is Dan bongino with I
believe rumble's invested in that as
well I think so so we want to build this
parallel economy you launched locals
yeah and then you sold to rumble yeah
and then we had a discussion about that
uh Ian said you were selling out and I
don't remember the entire the details
but this is what brings us to what we're
we're here now Dave's in the room and
Ian is just fuming and seeing red I'm
throwing the knife in the middle of
steam coming off my shoulders and
sweating uh it transitions brilliant
because we're talking about culture we
need to build culture we need to make
movies we need to get people on our side
vibrationally they want to want people
to walk into a room and people to be
like yes whatever you say it's a little
culty but you need that to change the
cult to change politics I think you need
control and culture but you also need
control of Technology because if you
control the technology no matter how
much good movies people are trying to
put out there you can just turn them off
so that kind of brings me to locals
which you were running at the time
um so you you started locals what my I
had two tiers of issues when you sold it
I think is my problem and the first one
was a bit more personal the other one's
more um I guess idealistic is that you
said come to locals I'll make sure you
never get banned and then sold the
company I was like well now he can't
make sure you never get banned because
he sold out I think I use the phrase
sold out to rumble whatever you saw the
company yeah
the other one is that I'm just concerned
with corporate conglomeration and
proprietary software because if Chris
gets killed you know Chris pavlovski if
something happens to him and then
someone else just owns everything all
the code so I think that we need to free
the software code so so I got yourself
that's a separate issue but yeah but but
I I the one issue that that we brought
up I thought was really important was
they're doing the SPAC deal which means
they're they're going to go public well
they're through it now right you mean
back then when you were having the
discussion yeah so that means BlackRock
State Street and Vanguard will buy
chunks of this company and then it will
be absorbed into that machine so can we
let's just do one thing at a time here
so first off on the on the why so in
essence we merged the company's
basically merged I want I will tell you
100 uh honestly I sold all for stock
because I believe in it I did not take
any cash in the deal I still consult for
them that's the extent of what I do with
the company but I am telling you without
question there has never been a tech
company built in in any sense that we
know anything of that it is free speech
is baked into the ethos of this company
when I started locals our idea was you
know we wanted to basically personalize
a patreon for people so that you'd have
an app that would give you direct
contact with your audience and you could
build a business on your own so we sort
of viewed it as like we're building you
a house and what you do in your house is
up to you that's how we dealt with free
speech and we never had any problems
about it also because you have a paywall
which eliminates 99.9 percent of all bad
behavior so we had I felt we had a bunch
of good systems in place to to clean it
up in a really nice way and I think and
then it became very successful and we
got great investors in all of those
things I had a talk with uh we had a
couple offers to buy the company I had
to offer for massive cash life-changing
cash offer I had the offer in hand can
you say from home uh no but I had the
offer in hand good people bad people uh
good good actually
um and I went to Peter Thiel for advice
purely for advice and I said here's is
the offer what do you think I should do
with this thing and he said and I said
Peter I know this number that I'm
showing you is not a lot to you he's got
billions and millions of dollars but I
was like but it is life-changing for me
and my brother-in-law who's running
who's the CEO who's running the tech
change my sister's life change my
family's life right there and Peter said
look I'm looking at your numbers you
guys are doing some great things here he
said all you need is distribution if you
can figure out what your distribution
model is you have something amazing and
then I think it was literally like two
weeks later we got a call from Chris can
you guys meet me in Miami for lunch and
we were thinking okay we can partner up
with them somehow we'll figure out
something and Chris within I think the
water wasn't even poured I think the
woman was coming over with the water and
he was like let's figure out how to
merge and do this thing together I'm
telling you everyone on the board at
Rumble is in this thing for free speech
for every issue we've discussed here can
BlackRock and other companies figure out
ways to buy parts of course they can of
course they can I'm not going to tell
you that they can't Chris I don't know
what the numbers are so don't me on this
exactly Chris controls something like 74
percent of the company right now I think
that's it's something like that
um and he is an absolute All-Star on all
of these issues so if this type of deal
I don't mean this to you specifically if
this type of deal is not good enough for
someone like here you you know me right
like I started in this thing fighting
Tech censorship all of the nonsense that
New York Times was calling us all right
and all these things I started this
company for the right reasons we found
another company that's in it for the
right reasons at some point it's like
you got to do deals to grow and be
bigger and be and mature these things
and scale them and all of those things
um are we a perfectly decentralized
system we are not are we working on some
things including decentralized payments
and subscriptions we absolutely are
um that's like yeah the issue uh for one
all of that positive all of it that's
positive across the board and that's why
we use Rumble infrastructure for
everything plus also you can't be Google
alone let me just throw anything in like
for me like I would was running a
company that was a side job that I was
only losing money on right because I'm
putting time and resources into it and
but I didn't mind that like I actually
loved building it but like okay so now
Dave is somehow just through locals I'm
gonna be like I honestly think we can
beat Google I really believe that so
here's here's the trajectory I see
right now Rumble is operating off of
what I assume is like spec money or
investor cash
well this back is closed and now it's
fully public and traded on NASDAQ and
everything so yeah so they have they
have the money from the pipe and all
that yeah so so there's a lot of cash
there so the profit uh Revenue
generation for rumble is substantially
less than their cost their liabilities
exceed their their assets at this point
I would imagine
at a certain point there's going to be
an obligation to the shareholders to
generate Revenue
like Twitter what I see happening is
they eventually say how do we attract
advertisers that's how we have to make
money on this one or subscriptions
you're then going to run into one of two
problems advertisers are going to say we
will not advertise on this content
because it offends our delicate ESC
sensibilities you get no money from us
that's less of a problem with Rumble
because of rumble's founding whereas
Twitter was like hey our investors want
money we're going to go for it we're
going to appease the next issue is the
financial services which is why
um parallel economy is so important and
I think Rumble sees this well Dan who
started parallel economy is also a
founder of Rumble these things these
things are connected like when I tell
you that the people involved in these
things when I have been to any meeting
with these people when I when we were
trying to figure out the merger I never
heard anyone say anything related to
speech in any way that would have made
any of it doesn't mean yeah Twitter used
to be the freeze between the Free Speech
party until their obligation to their
investors and then the advertiser said
oh yeah we'll advertise if you ban that
guy with patreon they they banned Robert
Spencer because it was reported that I
think MasterCard ordered them to do it
yeah and the response from the CEO of
patreon was if we don't ban this one guy
10 000 people lose their livelihood and
my response was let the hundred million
fans of those 10 000 people send an
angry letter to MasterCard when that
happens yeah so well you know I had him
on my show and he was lying to my face
it was pretty honest exactly so I think
Jack Conte yeah I think these are
potential pitfalls to going public
getting investor money eventually the
bill comes due and and rumble's gonna
have an obligation to public
shareholders as to how they generate
revenue and what that means so I would
also say so I it's totally legit I think
another piece of that that I think makes
it a little bit easier uh for somebody
like you to understand or not to
understand but to appreciate would be
that the the advertising game really is
changing right now like the cancel thing
it's not that it's gone but but I think
the days of oh Ben Shapiro said
something about abortion now the soothe
app is not gonna right like go it just
doesn't work anymore we are getting to
the other side of it the Chappelle thing
that we started with is evidence that
we're getting to the other side of it
there also are all sorts of companies
now because of what the woke have done
that companies are now being built in
across all sorts of Industries
to build to make hats and do all the
culture stuff you're talking about
whatever it might be whatever product so
there's a whole new industry being built
that will support this sort of thing
that did not exist five years ago that's
just a reality but yes some of this
stuff has to be played out and yes when
you're a public company you have
different obligations than a purely
private company Elon has a lot of Elon
owns this thing now he's gonna have a
lot of problems when he realizes how
much money it's losing every day can I
just ask you one question because you
said locals have the ethos and the
belief system of freedom of speech what
made you believe that Rumble was going
to continue that because you made a
statement saying believe me these guys
are standing behind it what made you
believe that these guys were going to
follow those same ethos uh as you had
with locals so first off I assume like
all of you guys but especially you Tim
when when you've done what we do for
long enough like the idea that I would
cross my audience is so not not say
something they don't like but like do
something so fundamentally against what
I have put out there and what I believe
in it's I like I physically would not be
able to do it so I knew that I could I
couldn't I couldn't just sell it and be
like all right now they're going to
screw all you guys like and I wouldn't
do that it's against who I am but but
that's not the answer you're looking for
every meeting that we had with Chris all
he kept talking about was the free and
open Internet that was it that every
time we would get into more nitty-gritty
stuff he would punt some of that to The
Tech Guys because what he wanted to talk
about was saving ninja is the guy who's
from Toronto Canada dealing with all I
mean if you think about everything that
Canadians have dealt with in the last
two years covid and how could we help
the truckers like we were doing all
sorts of stuff uh how you know like we
every single person the board now I know
the board like these people are in it
for the right reasons it is not the
perfect force field
um for some of the reasons that you
mentioned but it's pretty damn good
Rumble also has a lawsuit right now
against Google that's gonna you know
that we won discovery on so Rumble is
going to get access basically to the
Google algorithm unless Google unless
Google preemptively you can Google you
can Google it that's good
Google
search it yeah
no no no don't even do that they work
with George Soros when it comes to oh
this information I saw that and all that
but was there any kind of guarantees in
a contract saying hey this is how we run
locals we want you to run locals this
way as well we want to guarantee that
you will do it this way or was it just I
met him I liked them this is this is
what I want
um I can't speak to anything that was in
the contract genuinely I don't know and
I'm not even I don't even know if I like
I would be allowed to say it if I if I
did but I honestly don't know
um I can tell you that my brother-in-law
who is running the company still he is
the CEO of locals still he has run this
thing with all of the same ethos and
passions that we all have he's running
the locals end of it Chris is running
the rumble end of it
um yeah like we're we're in this fight
for the right reasons and and we have
the right people for the right reasons
look look who else were the big money
backers of this thing I mean teal put in
a lot of money you may have what I have
no issues with them I like them a lot
but like he's on our side in the
libertarian sense well let me let me ask
you one one quick question before we go
to super chats um what's what's Peter
thiel's net worth it's like 2 billion I
would you could Google that too but yeah
there's a b there's a B I kind of feel
like he could snap his fingers and win
the culture war and I wonder why you
know the technology is not the solution
to this I think it is yes I think it is
I think if you bring the software code
and created that centralized network
will not Inspire young people to stand
up for a liberal values what are you a
chance to see my movie otherwise I think
I might have a good I think I might have
a good answer for you so is your
proposition that he should just say
here's a billion dollars to the creators
of the world and go create not
necessarily I think I think he should
have a product he should indirectly have
a production house that produces movies
and shows Comics cartoons and video
games because this is what inspires
young people and and drives uh you know
yeah culture the stories that kids hear
growing up it influences how they decide
to live their lives and what they value
yeah so I do know that he he was all
about the uncollege thing I remember
when he did that with uh um to be in the
teal Fellowship you have to not have
gone to college and that's brilliant
yeah so I'm not saying he's doing
nothing but I'm wondering is it just
that he's got his focus and he's doing
things we don't know about or
um I can't speak for him I know I can
tell you that at the height of the IDW
thing when that thing was really blowing
up with Jordan and Ben and me and Rogan
and whoever there were some discussions
around it it was getting very complex
because of Egos and different business
models and all of those things
um
I don't yeah I can't speak for him I
honestly I don't know it's video games
yeah it's uh it's it's you make a you
make a video game a triple A game I know
it's expensive we're talking tens of
millions of dollars yeah I wonder if you
know what what do you do with billions
of dollars I know that he's invested in
winning for for values of Liberty yeah
but I wonder if it's just not within his
uh frame of mind to to see the world
this way you know that's interesting
look I mean keep in mind this was the
co-founder of PayPal with Elon right so
they obviously they have strengths that
worked well together and there's
something that's putting that Lego piece
together there Elon is doing I would say
in essence what you're asking for right
because it's a it's a culture play and a
Tech play you don't think that's totally
absolutely but look what it's doing at
the cultural level it does have sort of
a story I get it I get it it's not the
direct you want the direct line to
creativity or something this is more
it's it's good got Tech in between it is
good but um you you look at uh
Tick Tock is a big component so Tech is
there
Tick Tock is controlling what these kids
can see and what they did what they're
being told is cool and what's not cool
but it's also music being played on on
the streaming platforms music videos
kids grow up and they want to be like
what what what is viewed as popular
among their peer group what's being
funded is these Tech billionaires who
have money for obvious reasons view the
world through a technical a technology
lens and not through a cultural lens and
Democrats have always tried to own
celebrities and the Arts and that's what
inspires young people that's what makes
them feel cool yeah I guess yeah I can't
speak for for I can't speak for him so I
don't know the answer to that but I
don't but I do sense that it's changing
I mean look we're taught look where
again where did we start we started with
Chappelle who's pretty damn red pill now
so like the thing is happening the
biggest podcaster in the world is Joe
Rogan he's pretty red pilled like said
he would vote for DeSantis so the things
are happening in front of our eyes so
the question is what do you do with all
of those pieces a few thoughts simple
and overt is one thing that we're trying
to do and I I'm not trying to suggest
anyone should do anything we're doing
you know I I view the world a certain
way I'll take action the way I do uh we
don't want any competition oh I I love
the competition to be fantastic what I
don't want is to tell someone else to do
something and then be wrong right
because then they've taken a risk at my
behest and screwed them I don't want
that I'll take the risks on my uh on my
own you know with what we have and then
if we're wrong I like the
decentralization of it I think
funding more uh cultural commentators
who push back on the machine the
conservatives are so are so stodgy you
know what I mean you look at TP USA and
we're friends with a lot of those people
but they're suit wearing stodgy and that
doesn't resonate with your average city
kid or anything like that they're not
going to grow up and be like man I wish
I could wear a suit too and be stodgy
they wanna they wanna fit in with their
peer group who dress down and don't do
those things my my idea would be um
certainly if I had billion a billion
dollars I'd set aside a couple million
to just fund Tick Tock YouTube channels
um comedians who are challenging the the
woke cancel culture who are funny find
Talent creative production house create
a talent agency make shows make movies
make content that floods the market and
then you look at uh an example of a
movie The Craft which the second version
was super woke and insane yeah first one
was good they have insane money to fund
this ridiculous well garbage and the
best the right can muster up is the
daily wire which is having a difficult
time of doing it the daily wire is
putting their profits towards this
project trying really really hard to
take the cultural space meanwhile there
are billionaires who have no obligation
to do so right but if they wanted when
the culture War could be like I can set
aside money for for a lower budget high
quality cultural content to challenge
system without as much risk I say the
daily wire could yeah one last one last
Quick comments tln musk also sold PayPal
now PayPal wants to find people for
disinformation that's why people are
critical of companies selling companies
because it's like what could happen now
that's the larger question for sure and
if you think about it so now now you
have teal doing basically we're all
agreeing it's basically good work I get
you want him to be more involved you
have musk doing his thing with Twitter
David sacks has been one of the most uh
outspoken anti-ukraine War people I
think in the country who is the CEO of
PayPal so these guys might be forming
again in some way to do something who
knows who knows that's what I'm getting
super chats all right if you haven't
I'll leave it unresolved would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show coming up at 11 PM which
should be good fun let's read some Super
Chat smash that like button Adam Noel
says Dave I'm a huge fan your appearance
on Club random was great get Tim an
introduction with Bill keep up the good
fight God bless I got Bill Maher to say
there are conditions to which he would
move to Florida and vote for DeSantis
that's pretty I I but then of course the
day before the election he's out there
saying Democrat you have to vote
Democrats democracy I watch some of the
uh your talk with Bill are and uh
were you aggressive with him
well we had to figure it out the thing
is it was two hours it's the longest one
he's ever done and for the first half
hour you could watch us both trying to
like is he trying to take me out am I
trying to take him out we're kind of
dancing back and forth he was also
asking me a lot about sex which I did
not really want to talk about and it
felt kind of gross or whatever but then
about a half hour and we broke through
and then the one thing that they said to
me before the show is they can't that
the show itself cannot be mostly
politics that was the way that was the
way HBO signed off on it that he has to
be mostly doing something else but I
knew ever but I did want to talk and
talk to him about politics obviously and
he wanted to talk to me about certain
things so we had to kind of get there
um but wait what was your question did I
were you aggressive
um I wouldn't say I was aggressive I
think it I think it was as good as it
could have possibly been for the first
foray into that and uh I think I'm gonna
be on real time in in January and we'll
hopefully keep doing that thing yeah I I
I I've been asked by people that are in
the circle with him or have known him if
if I would be interested in having him
here or be interested in going on real
time I would not go on real time I get
it but it's not overly political it's
like it's a big investment to fly to LA
to do a show that's less informed than
than our show is and have to desperately
try to cling uh for I'll give you I'll
just exemplify this uh when Prager went
on yes and said there are tampons and I
want to washroom and they all laughed
yeah it's like you want me to go into a
room full of people who are less
informed about the world than I am and
then I have to desperately try to
explain that to them in a matter of
minutes is just a terrible investment
well that's why the moment when I said
to Bill that we talked about earlier
when I said to Bill uh you do know that
Hillary Clinton called Trump an
illegitimate president and he he
immediately no no she didn't no she
didn't but it was like Bill actually
there are tweets here's the video they
pull it up for you yeah exactly so I get
I fully get that he told me I'm gonna do
the first uh the protected interview
just him you know the one-on-one so that
at least we can get something done but
you know it's one of those things I
wanted to do it for so long and now it's
like I feel like I got I made my piece
with it I had this great conversation
with this guy that I admired maybe we
went in slightly different play you know
places but we're gonna play ball
together and I'd love to I'd love to
have him here I think the show would end
up going five hours because what's gonna
happen is uh I love using Hunter Avalon
as an example of this uh sorry Hunter
but uh he was this conservative who then
became liberal I don't know if you've
ever heard of him the name sounds
familiar but a conservative who became
liberal that's right he was an anti-sjw
personality did some interviews some
liberals and then also became a leftist
and he came on this show and it was a
moment where I mentioned that Joe Biden
said quid pro quo if you don't fight the
prosecutor you're not getting the
billion dollars and he went that never
happened and I said yes it did and I
pulled the video up right away when we
played it yeah and then he was like I
didn't know and I was like don't come in
here and tell me like we sit here all
day like I'm certainly not right about
everything yeah but this is the problem
people like Bill saying Hillary never
said that my response to bill is just
bill have you heard of Google it's
remarkable to me that he spends so much
of his time smugly and assuredly talking
about politics he never actually looks
into it's like he has his staff right
for him and then he just believes it to
his credit so I agree with some of that
criticism and I've said some of that
publicly to his credit what I would say
is by doing this podcast he's trying to
break out of that agree I think that's
what's happening I think he realized
that maybe there really were some blind
spots and some controls around real time
that maybe he was starting because the
guests suck now if you look at that
guest list every Friday like that it's a
it's a collection of nobodies where it
used to be All-Stars on there every week
no I know that that might have been the
peak of the show in a weird sense yeah
because it was really like blowing up
sort of culturally or whatever and that
was the airlocked mainstream bill so uh
he was like the first victim of cancer
culture I think in 2001
politically incorrected he was talking
about the war I don't know what exactly
he said dude yeah he said that you can
say what you want about the hijackers
but you can't say that they were cowards
because they did what they want they did
what they intended to do and that and
then people basically made it seem like
he was saying that they were Brave or
something like that and within what a
week two weeks the show was canceled I
think it I think it might have been two
or three months if I'm not mistaken and
this is before internet video so it was
before he could just spin up a podcast
and so he suffered through it in that I
got to talk to him about this like what
was it like he's been like living in
that system of censorship I remember it
very well because I was doing stand-up
at the time I was I've always been a
huge fan of bills I wanted to be on
Politically Incorrect and people thought
he was done people really did think he
was done it was before you could do
podcasts and everything so he wasn't
guaranteed that HBO had never done a
talk show like that so he looks like he
could be my dad 20 years later yeah for
sure
let's read some more we got uh daddy bad
bad says timcast routinely compares the
fall of Rome to what is happening in USA
but I think the disintegration of the
Soviet Union would make a better
predictor
I actually uh the last thing I said
about it was that it may actually be the
rise of the Roman Empire not the fall
the crossing of the Rubicon and the
creation of the Empire which resulted in
200 years of prosperity the fall of the
Roman Republic right right although the
Soviet thing is interesting because it's
a bunch of oligarchs split the country
apart and decided who got what Waterway
and that's the big part of the Ukraine
Russia thing not because the oligarchs
were like were you given the Black Sea
to Ukraine and there's a lot of powerful
oligarchs right now so they would want a
piece you know I don't know what do you
think
I had some more thing about build a wall
and Berlin Wall came down and we should
build a wall around Florida I kind of
left the room for a minute mentally I
was putting that all together
interesting yeah all right Josh says
what are your thoughts on Arizona's HB
2289 and the RNC completely ignoring it
do you know which one that is Luke no
neither do I you're gonna look at it I
don't know what that one is either wow
we'll read this uh while you do Steven
Steele says Oz didn't win because he
wasn't Maga enough
perhaps uh there was a Kathy Barnett
Trump could have endorsed her and she
was she's wicked smart but he went with
Oz because I guess he thought TV
celebrity could play but would play
better
I mean the fact that Oz lost veteran is
it's just it doesn't matter how do you
live that down it doesn't matter right
who would you lose to uh you don't want
to know also also that Oprah who put Oz
on the map endorse fetterman like it's
Oz he's got it and I I met him a few
weeks ago he's a decent dude like he
wasn't going to be all the things
Republicans wanted to be but he was a
nice enough guy I got this HB 2289 in
Arizona this bill the overview says
outlines requirements related uh
relating to appointed political party
Challengers for polling places it's a
bit big but it's a bill not sure yeah
let's see Balian says bro you think AZ
is bad AK hadn't even gotten through the
first round of ranked Choice BS you keep
saying RC is great but it's not it
incentivizes low info people who don't
do their due diligence and uh and
research the candidates
ranked Choice voting I think the there's
there's there's Arguments for and
against it one argument against it is
that ranked Choice results in the status
quo I was winning
because what people want to believe if
we do ranked Choice voting everyone's
going to put Bernie Sanders for number
one and then Hillary Clinton and Bernie
wins and what really happens is
10 of people put Bernie ten percent of
people put Nader 10 of people put Trump
ten percent of people put John Smith and
then all of those fall back on my plan B
which is again just gonna be the garbage
establishment candidate
the uh the pro argument is that many
Libertarians would say I'm vote in
libertarian but I guess I'll take the
Republican if I have no choice and then
you'd see uh uh Walker win in um in
Georgia
what happens in a ranked choice if
there's two candidates candidate one
candidate two you fifty percent of the
people say I vote for candidate one with
two is my second choice fifty percent
say I have over candidate two with one
is my choice who wins you mean 50 50.
yeah the same thing that happens with
any tie it usually goes to a runoff a
special election or I mean I don't think
we've actually ever seen a direct tie
before because it's so statistically
it would probably be literally
impossible yeah which is why these
49.79
it would have to be an even number of
Voters and it would have to fall
perfectly split 50 50 and then they'd
probably have to do a special I don't
know that's where this all ends in 2024
isn't it the perfect example
that's the movie that is and then we
agree we don't need a federal government
and we could rule our own lives through
state and local officials here's this is
interesting Wyatt kaldenberg says I
voted for fetterman because he was more
trump-like than the than that upper
class neocon Dr Oz elitist Oz kept the
working class away from voting GOP
interesting I mean look there were
Bernie voters who voted for Trump I
would not be surprised if there are
Trump voters who preferred fetterman
these are people who are not staunch
conservatives not DieHard Trump
supporters they were populist leftists
who said I guess Trump's better than
Hillary when given an option to vote for
fetterman even if he's struggling to
speak they want a populist leftist over
an elitist celebrity who eats crudite
God despite all the crime stuff and all
that stuff all right I'm not saying it's
everybody there's got to be somebody
yeah
let's grab some more Nathan Heim says
shout out to Ian I always appreciate the
energy and perspective you have
thank you Nathan thank you Cal Miller
says after the 2022 midterms I think the
chance of Civil War has gone down the
left is Unified and the right is too
divided I
completely disagree I think it's gone
substantially up because if there was
this talk of this great Red Wave and
Trump supporters thought they had a path
forward and then this is what happened
because Universal mail and voting I fear
that as John F Kennedy said those who
make peaceful Revolution impossible make
violent revolution inevitable it doesn't
mean it's always the majority are people
who are right who feel that way but if
people on the right field
disenfranchised because no matter how
hard they push they're not winning
people are going to lose their minds and
I hope that's not the case because if
the Republicans assuming they do take
the house they're going to get
everything they could have wanted out of
this what else could they have gotten I
mean a little bit more for sure winning
the Senate could have put Rand Paul in a
position to challenge fouchy and all
this stuff but the house can do that
they'll still be able to do it you don't
need Rand Paul for that and then you can
blame the Democrats for everything come
2024 and if you are able to take this
this this this time to file the lawsuits
to go after the universal mail-in voting
and challenge all the stuff that you
have a chance for 2024 to actually win
the Democrats are already to blame for a
lot of things lockdowns inflation
Ukraine uh you know almost starting a
world war with Russia they have enough
to be blamed for already I don't think
adding more to that's going to help very
very important question this is very
very good Rhiannon tunell just thank you
so much Dave are you going to get
chickens buck buck
I had chickens when I was in LA and then
my my 16 year old dog had cancer and it
was we were putting a lot of effort into
her decided to let the chickens go to
some friends who were free-ranging them
the chickens are doing all right we had
great chicken names you don't have all
chicken names do you named all the
chickens uh they all have names so we we
named the original batch and then the
viewers of chicken City have elected
names for them we had Blanche featherow
we had feather Locklear we had um we had
oh Princess Leia because she Leia the
eggs we had hensaki oh that's good and
we had Shuan egg and unfortunately they
both passed uh yeah well that's gonna
happen where were you in La that you had
chickens I was in Sherman Oaks in the
valley it was crazy hot in the backyard
it didn't make a lot of sense I was
mostly just keeping them cool all day
long uh but anyway now it now I would
love to get chickens in Florida yeah
then I have I have space to do it um but
you know I also have two I have a three
month old and a one month old so it's
I'm a little stretched that's true dude
how's being a dad
it's pretty good it's pretty good so far
you know there's a lot of pooping and
crying and screaming and now we have
kids involved so it's a lot well there
you go now there's even more poop and
crunch no it's been it's been really
nice
Choice music says to fix the vote one
remove d and r two list policies claimed
or voted for next to candidate names
three video recording of every vote
required four days to vote with
designated PTO by name per day
it's interesting if we record people
voting but not who they voted for to
confirm they did vote would be
interesting or at the very least uh some
record showing that they did I agree
with removing Democrat republican from
belts I don't think they should be on it
yeah yeah I think you can argue it
either way I tell you some extent it's
like you go so many people go in there
even people that are fairly well
informed you still go in not knowing a
couple things don't vote for someone you
don't know I would say generally
speaking you should vote for a
republican you don't know if at least as
it stands right now but here's what
would happen in my opinion yeah your
move DNR it makes it very difficult for
ballot Harvesters they're going to say
vote Democrat which one's that you're
right and they're going to be like just
all the way down the line yeah so but
what they'll do is they'll say anyone
with a d check the box and they do now
they're gonna go and say vote for the
Democrats who's that okay you've got
Steve Smith that's the first line okay
next you're gonna have that's that's
that's John Doe much much more difficult
and I don't know if they're legally
allowed to do that you might be allowed
to say hey I think you should vote
Democrat but I don't know if they're
able to tell you to dictate to on the
list you get rid of that D makes it very
difficult the next thing uh with it that
I think is good is informed voters know
who they're voting for you know Ron
DeSantis you don't care he's a
republican you're going in and hitting
that Ron DeSantis you know you want
carry like you vote Carrie like ignorant
voters will struggle well-informed
voters will succeed and you're voting
for the person not some ideology so I
think remove DNR from ballots right away
yeah I still think there's probably some
problem down ballot where even
well-informed people just don't know a
slew but but but if you're going in and
being like I know DeSantis I don't know
who that guy is I'm gonna vote for him
anyway you deserve the leadership you
get you should be like you should be
like I know DeSantis I know Rubio I
don't know these other guys I'm not
going to vote for them but let's put it
this way if you look at what happened in
Florida I mean he now has a super
majority it's in part because a whole
bunch of people were like I'd like to
say at this and I'm voting Republican
all the way down and it also caused
Rubio to win you know by 15 points or
something that's crazy too yeah Rubio
should not have won by double digits I
mean he's he's pretty he's pretty
standard stuff I think I think he might
get some Mojo out of Florida right now
but it's it's good that he won and it's
good that he won big all right Juan
yuchan says hi Dave you need to help Tim
get on P BD podcast or get Patrick on
timcast Tim Poole and Patrick David are
two of the best thinkers and podcasts of
our time of course Dave you are too yeah
I'm not familiar who's Patrick Bet David
he does value attainment he was a big I
think he was like a massive investor guy
moved his whole company down to Florida
they're in Fort Lauderdale he's totally
great dude I was on a show this week uh
yeah happy to do it he's yeah you should
do it he's doing like a sort of it's
kind of this we got to figure out how to
get out of this but they wear suits ah
suit suits see Juiced cyber new type
says Florida needs to take over the rest
of the U.S Florida imperialism has this
answer descendants considered forming a
a a a a ground force well wasn't he
going to create they he had his own
police and people were freaking out but
perhaps he can then send them to
liberate to Liberty and then then we can
just change the country the entire name
just becomes Florida oh so you are going
down those route I would be for how
about some population trades you know
what I mean just like an NBA trade
before the deadline like let's just take
some sane families out of New York some
sane you know decent people out of New
York and let's trade them for whatever's
going on in Orlando with the
purple-haired weirdos I I disagree let
Florida man be Florida man we gotta we
got an important one here James moaning
says first genocide is a great song I
really do appreciate it says can't wait
for more second Iowa swept red great
state third keep an eye on the railroads
the votes extended to 12-4 and it
doesn't look good if they strike it will
be bad for all
not just the railroad strikes but we're
hearing that travel strikes may happen
too which can be very very bad for
Christmas and New Year's so we know that
I think what pilots went on strike
recently is that what happened Luke well
there was a conversation after a major
Pilot's union meeting and Pilots coming
out saying there's a big probability
that there might be boycotts this coming
season so look out for that that's just
not what we need right now for the
holiday season after all this craziness
yeah not what we need but but it's okay
for the ultra wealthy who will just fly
private without masks or restrictions
while the poor people can barely afford
all right Juiced also says that Trump
has a big obstacle now that Dems won't
even need to debate anymore I mean uh
Biden barely wanted to debate in the
first place and now they're not debating
so maybe Trump's boisterous attitude I
think they learned I think they saw how
the debate wouldn't that be something if
the Democrats just pull a Katie hops
going forward nope you're just not doing
it we're just not no if it's Trump we we
he's Hitler exactly they'll say we will
not allow I will not give him the
promotion he's requesting we won't do it
oh man and then that takes away what
you're saying basically is Trump's
secret thing right the one thing that
you've given him over over DeSantis and
and desantis's uh where he's probably
weakest is
well I don't know how he would fare in
debate but he doesn't come off as the
same kind of boisterous personality As
Trump but if they don't if they don't
debate him then it helps DeSantis yeah
I got policy behind his back he doesn't
need to prove himself on a stage with
somebody I remember Trump but during the
debates in 2016 was spectacular 2020 I
don't really remember him doing that no
well with Biden unless no that that's
what I was saying earlier he seems to be
better in The Fray right when there's a
scrum and there's a bunch of people no
he did well with Hillary when it was him
and Hillary one on one he was doing
really good with that go to jail that
wasn't really good though saying that
you're gonna throw your political
opponent in jail is not good no well it
worked for the base though I mean it got
it did get him it helped get him elected
for sure it got aroused it's not
effective it's over the Nazis okay but I
don't understand your point they're not
they're not the Nazis either right yeah
I think he was all right I think he was
a little off his game in 2020 because
kobit was so freaking crazy that and he
had just recovered from covid in one of
the debates like he just wasn't fully
himself yeah killer donut says as a West
Virginian that moved to Florida I will
gladly take the humidity over
snowmageddon plus tons of activities you
could be like the snowbirds come down in
the winter leave in the summer thank you
you know uh winter does doesn't last
that long it doesn't actually snow that
much out here it snowed I think last
year like twice and snowboarding is fun
uh I gotta tell you we get just the
right amount of winter you you rent a
little cabin you know a couple hours
North and maybe the mountains somewhere
in Pennsylvania and you get this you get
a cabin with big glass windows right in
front and you sit back with the fire
going in a hot cocoa and slippers on and
you just watching the snow come down at
night that's just crying thinking about
Florida yeah absolutely exactly you know
we're thinking about swimming in the hot
Ocean and the Sun and getting some
vitamin D which is really good and and
important for your body we have all the
seasons here and so you get the hot you
go you go on the river you get the cold
you go snowboard you get Springtime you
go skating yeah Florida's great for you
know to visit in the winter sometime you
want to you want to get a taste of that
good good summer Vibes and then you come
back and you enjoy that you got snow Tim
I know you need to believe this so I'm
gonna let you have it look I'm from
Chicago we have we uh what is Chicago
technically have two seasons it has
freezing cold and super hot and yeah so
you know I like getting I like the mix I
like San Diego it's always 69 degrees
and but it gets a little foggy in the
mornings but La is great man LA weather
really but it rains it rains fire every
few months you know yeah the crazy fires
the problem with LA is not the weather
it's the people communism
the brake dust I guess yeah and the air
quality blows there it really it's just
it's really bad
all right agamemnon's gym gym bag says
Dave neat guy but I very much disagree
remove r d from ballots you can
literally fire up the internet machine
and figure out the candidates you want
while you are in line if you're not
willing to do that you probably
shouldn't be voting yeah I don't I don't
feel particularly strong about it either
way I think I think your argument before
is was sound and I think there's reasons
to when it's working that you just get
some extra votes for the right Democrats
would be panicking if DNR were moving
yeah yeah yeah Republicans you like
people are wondering like how is it that
you know some people voted for this
Republican but not that Republican in
Arizona and it's like because Republican
voters vote based on their candidate by
doing research and so they might
sometimes actually refer to this party
this can be a problem sometimes yep and
Democrats are just going to be like
Democrat Democrat Democrat Democrat
I say you take that uh Matt Anthony says
Katie Hobbs just one AZ sucks
we will see but yeah yeah probably which
was surprising and I know the left is a
uh because they they operate based on a
lack of context I did a couple segments
saying the the trend suggests carry like
will win and that's actually what the
forecasters were predicting and what the
trends were predicting the trends were
showing that the late bouts that were
coming in were actually beginning to
favor Kerry Lake increasingly and uh AZ
Central reported that Kerry Lee Kerry
Lake had more than enough votes left to
actually win in the end like we saw in
2020 with the late battles coming in
they were absentee early they were late
drop off absentee however they said it's
possible that she still does lose no one
really wants to say they think this will
follow 2020 trends so ultimately they
sound it sounds like it didn't and
Carrie like was not able to uh muster up
enough votes well the question is what
will Kerry do we will see my friends if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member at timcast.com because
we're going to have that members only
exclusive uncensored show coming up in
just a little bit you don't want to miss
it you can follow the show at timcastirl
on Instagram and everywhere else you can
follow me personally at timcast do it
Dave do you want to shout anything out
uh you know I started a tech company hey
and you can find out what we're doing
over at reubenreport.locals.com right on
thanks for coming on uh my website is
youtube.com forward slash we are change
I've been screaming about the FTX
Scandal the last few days the world
economic Forum the clintons Tony Blair
they're all involved here the story is
crazy I've made a number of videos about
it talk about the members only and then
on Luke uncensor.com I even talked about
an Epstein FTX possible link you want to
see that Luke uncensored.com there yeah
the FTX thing is one of the greatest uh
fiscal scandals of Our Generation
honestly maybe in my lifetime one of the
great and it's crypto it's new people
are don't know what to do about it the
government's pulling their hair out they
were in the uh Bahamas that's where it's
all going down not even an American soil
but if a lot of American money in there
I'm interested to talk about it let's
talk about it Florida man I love you
brother see you see we worked it out
it's like the founding fathers man they
didn't always agree but they worked
together anyway
that's right Dave is just like Thomas
Jefferson thank you thank you it's like
one of the designers with my slaves
don't be Benjamin Franklin
I think rumble's in a position to
decentralize the internet and and make
free software like the law of the land
I'm really excited Chris has also I've
had this conversation a good dude we're
working on a lot of stuff cool young
guys get it I love Chris all right see
you guys uh you can find me everywhere
at Kellen PDL Dave it's great to meet
you love the conversation right I
appreciate it we will see you all over
at timcast.com head over there click the
join us button and the members only will
be live in about an hour thanks for
hanging out sex with sleep